ladies gentlemen we're back on a Monday
morning thanks for every Monday thanks
for tuning in ladies and gentlemen it's
a lovely morning here in Southern
California Brian Brennan talking at your
life not really actually never what I
mean right but you know what I'm saying
you should forget some way to get it
going live do it long enough yeah you're
right but you know have the capability
we never edit really I mean we don't say
anything never at it you know
so as we'll do it what did you do this
weekend had fights had people over for
the fights or but at when I say people I
Joe's family over then our good friend
Todd Phillips mm-hmm don't mean
something and and did you like the
fights did you enjoy them how about
Demetrius John I thought and I and I
even tweeted out or social media out
that I was like and I feel like
tonight's gonna be a special night until
the last really to fight so I was like
boy was I wrong you could feel like
there's no energy in the crowd obviously
because the Vegas situation yeah all my
friends were at the fight Tony Jefferies
was in Vegas I obviously have close
friends still that work for the FC and
people who work in Vegas they're just
like I can't believe this fight still
going on and I was a fan of it going on
you mean they're still they're gonna
have it yeah still have it just because
it's a it's a bit of distraction for
everyone share and takes everyone's mind
off the fight with the tragedy you could
just tell there was I feel like there
was a lot of energy in the fighters in
the arena yeah and then the you know
that the Bobby Green fight was good but
I felt like he was pushing way too hard
night
wow this is the fight of the century
this is ridiculous it's all right
yeah it's all right and then the last
two fights were good but I didn't follow
why Derek Lewis was replaced what
happened he woke up and I guess his back
he's had issues before his back he just
couldn't move Wow he just couldn't move
what a seizure or something not a
seizure he's just he's had back problems
before that's when he thought about
retiring it's weird that it happens that
day that morning
and she did something to jerk or
something like that right that's a
little weird and I was looking forward
to that fight the most besides the main
event you were here so you feel don't
you feel that they would the same thing
to happen to wall Harris would have
happened to network absolutely not you
mean jujitsu eyes if you took him to the
ground I don't think they're absolutely
not really I mean if you would like
doubt you know Derrick Lewis a is tough
to take down very tough take down be
good like getting in there taking them
down to knock you out yeah you want six
in a row before you lasted mark cut
against tough guy yeah comparing him and
Walt Harris I mean Walt Harris looks
like a great athlete just looks like he
just stepped off a football field as a
defensive end yeah he's just you know
there's levels to this game here there's
levels in here you know in any division
heavyweight there's a bigger gap between
the 15th ranked guy in the number one
there's such a big gas in the other
divisions not so much at 125 35 45 55
even so at 70 the 15th ranked item
number one guy this evening given night
you know they could beat him wait no no
she's too much of a discrepancy they're
watching every weights like look at the
top 15 there's a reason why these old
heavyweights can stick around and these
other divisions they get aid the [ __ ] Oh
salty lions but uh yeah the other thing
I thought it was good to have the event
but they focused so much on the Vegas
yeah yeah well you want it I get you
address it I think in the beginning yeah
then you go about your business
yeah but they can't push in it they kept
but yeah there's this weird there's this
weird thing there's this weird dance
between the idea of how much you're
gonna let that piece of [ __ ] you know in
effect you know the good things in life
versus how much time do you give for
reverence reflection and communion but I
see the the reason why I was like yeah
you should carry on with the fight so
you give people an outlet to forget
about what happened last Sunday whatever
it was yellow eye Sunday yeah doing that
you don't keep bringing it up in putting
in people's faces we're all very aware
what happened correct it's a horrible
situation but you know the crowds pretty
dead you know and you know it's not
Yossi's fault I've seen this [ __ ]
[ __ ] who'd pulled this horrible tragedy
off but the whole top for the first time
was just blacked out there's known in
the top rafters they couldn't you know
can't give tickets away that's crazy
yeah rightfully selling senses what
who'd want to go to hell yeah [ __ ] yeah
you're just an inner group I'm gonna go
and get into a group again like into a
big stadium again go into a concert last
night and I was a god she's like you and
go Todd's like no no I just don't know
Thanks
I never liked that stuff anyway it
always yeah what um
what do you think of the Demetrius
Johnson yeah dr. deck had Bork fought
for boards Tommy but yet he's tough
super tough um I thought uh you know I
thought DJ look great I thought thank
God he got that finish special to beat
Anderson Silva's record yeah it's a
tough submission to pull off he's
finished
everybody has he not no know who's gone
the distance with there's been some guys
we don't need go through he hasn't
finished everyone yeah is that some
finished most guys thing
most guys have watched the last fights
have watched his Latin his last like
four or five yeah he's pulled some and
then and then so Tony Ferguson Kevin Lee
very good fight and I mean you know
pretty good but could you like yeah what
do you think about that this the shitty
thing about that was I feel like Tony
had the stage to kind of call Connor out
and do his thing and then the in
everyone knows I'm a Tony fan and the
cussing that he did like you can't use
that yeah no one can use that for promo
I can't can't use on Fox yet using the
pay-per-view they can't yeah what are
you gonna do with that yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] come [ __ ] get it all right
well that's gone yeah no one thought to
tell him like yeah and especially the
favorite and none of its corn member
like this is the angle we should play
rip this hot promo to get karmic ever
out calm a paper champ say you know I'm
not gonna fight unless I'm fighting
Conor McGregor that's the only [ __ ]
rhyme any nothin will not arrive you
have to be lame about it well no that's
what I'll he will do I'll he would do
that
sakes man rhyme no I'm just saying come
up with a game plan where you you get
Conor McGregor soundbite salamat would
you know at least acknowledge you won
the buy sound but I did not deem
acknowledge no so he could have went
about in a million ways you know a rhyme
for him the rhymes eyes thing you know
yeah yeah he's he's Tony Ferguson yeah
but he just he dropped the ball there
but Dana said that's the next fight I
almost feel like they have to say that
though what do you mean of course you're
gonna say that to establish some sort of
order yeah that you asked it that's
gonna be his next fight
maybe collars gonna tell you what he
wants to do next what what do you think
of that fight in terms of um based off
you know free since the fight against
Kevin Lee no Kevin Lee he was laying a
lot of good shots yeah you know but the
thing is is Kevin Ken Russell's ass off
Tony can Russell's ass off yeah that'd
be the different that kind of almost
that I want to say x-pac just makes
martial arts but that would be the issue
for Connors Tony's wrestling and
jiu-jitsu yeah Tony was it what's his
pedigree in wrestling I didn't know he
was that American team captain crazy
grandpa I didn't know I had no idea
oh really yeah yeah stud Kevin Lee also
wrestled there yes Kevin Lee took him
down I'm pretty yes he did you know yeah
but that dad that 10th planet Jiu Jitsu
that whole you know triangle yeah yeah
pretty wild yeah dad that does seem to
be the biggest liability Soto standing
with Conor I don't know what do you mean
you think Conor gets the the edge on
that you think Connors uh it's a good
fight but again Tony's wrestling jujitsu
would be could be some trouble mmm who
knows what we're gonna get yeah but but
I think you have to say that's next
otherwise it makes that belt like it was
worth nothing gorgeous that's what's
next yeah I think DJ's I think Demetrius
Johnson is pound for pound number one I
see people on social media like Oh what
happened to John Jones I used to hate on
the little guys no I still do but John
John I still do don't get it twisted but
John with his PD issues and just being a
bad human being in general you got to
take him out you can't you
beep and for palying its thing that win
with the UFC when somebody kind of stops
fighting you don't miss him like even
someone like John Jones I mean [ __ ]
keeps going on like you just keep we
just keep talking with the fights keep
going John she gonna do right I mean but
it's like it sucked it definitely sucks
we need guys rights socially the fights
that we're gonna happen the Steve do you
know anything about what's going on
nothing we have no final judgment on
this I mean it's you still gotta wait
for Nevada it wait for all that we're
trying to get the Machine oh no worries
you have to do that oh don't worry about
it I need more coffee like I need a
punch in the face
yeah but with John you gotta wait to see
what the Commission does from it I saw
something people sent me that says he
might not get a long suspension but it's
all hearsay you just gotta wait for the
Commission yeah he's missed though for
sure sue yeah do you leave the light
heavyweight division it says it means
yeah nothing gets you very excited right
what were the ratings in the prior so
good
we don't know yet I can't imagine the
once that we're on Fox we're good those
fights were awful and not and not a lot
of big names either but nope what else
what you do what else to do this weekend
I had the kids a full time mom / dad not
easy beastie yeah yeah Tiger all day
sunday all night Sunday yeah the Beast
we watched rolls three times great movie
though my daughter watched men in black
all three men in black those nearly
three ah you should gonna keep watching
them over and over
yeah like Tigard likes to watch
something simillar with oh yes Moana
when they're kids they'll watch that
over look what's wrong with you over
they will be familiar than I change them
Elsa not having it
there's so much to see for their little
brains in their little eyes we let you
see wanna yeah singing half step singing
we can't watch anything I don't have
things really Bubble Guppies Moana
trolls trolls right now is the hotness
poeple copies at mana Kendrick mmm-hmm
boy oh yeah I had to do some research on
her when Steiger went to bat she's
something else you
came up here odd way did you see her and
up in here oh yeah a great actress she's
ridiculous
she's amazing sing dance I mean that's a
school thesbian schooled man I mean
she's saying silent night for well in
front of the president been doing it
forever that's that's the Rory MacDonald
Rory MacDonald didn't do doing mm8 since
he was 13 Anna Kendrick she's been she's
been taking lessons I bet you she I bet
you I don't know but I bet you she's
from New York I think from an action
from the main clothes she's from Maine
okay close though I will promise you
that since she was a little kid she's
been in dance and singing class I'm sure
it was silly you can see it every time
and then what I like to do is when he
goes to bed just to see what's going on
because I know I'm be watching him more
I go googled behind the scenes as I
watched trolls with Anna Kendrick and
Justin Timberlake like doing the
voiceovers you know for that and the
Moana with the rock and all them it's so
interesting to me yeah man that's that's
that's good money they know for them
you'll be really think that's all I was
thinking how many people doing Johnson I
mean he can get it together but you also
have to have like a unique voice yeah
you do yeah you do and it's acting it's
real for sure and a lot of times you're
doing it not off of somebody you're
doing the lines separate yeah like the
rock and the girls the main girl in it
Moana didn't meet til it was like over
so if you're not in the same room now
back and forth you're just doing you
know it's I'm with trolls you know our
boy Skylar Astin is uh they're doing a
series on Netflix and he's the voice now
of what Justin Timberlake right movie
right as well he should be with his boy
the [ __ ] thing Aston man yeah the
kids will watch that [ __ ] over and over
and over again and then they get older
and then they just want new well I
prefer new right now yeah I know trolls
like the back of my hand I know every
song every Moana song I mean I'll do it
for him I will do it for him at night
before I put in bed I will sing the
guano songs hey guys here we go buddy
yeah we don't do the Jimmy Oh snake is
Thursday I can't work out you know I
like to work out every day so I know
Thursday won't better work out so into
the gym yesterday on a Sunday mm-hmm
weird out the long
two hours and you know me I never do
that stuff and then I've been today I am
I worked out today with coq10 without a
pope just drained yeah just drain on
that pup man that's why I'll nap the
other day we can that with kids Saturday
took two naps that put on a movie and I
took a little nappy-poo then about four
hours later I was like mmm didn't didn't
just don't feel the quickening if it's
called a quickening got a feel an energy
a pop nope got a lie down again took
another 10 minutes
I'm jealous man I took a 10-minute nap
and I woke up and I was like I feel
refreshed
god bless Amanda cuz that is not
happening at the shop household there's
I'm up at 5:45 a.m. Yami more it's young
right now we have to end up with there's
he has to wait - I make my coffee then
we go outside going our walk and there's
this do don't feed well you know I don't
give a [ __ ] you're listening the show
walking them older guys I see every
morning walk you older hairy gentlemen
because I see why can Sun every morning
you know I live right there I can set up
my window I'm like that's a little
creepy whatever I'm like very cool man
have a good good day keep going as
you're cute and you're I go no I know
he's ridiculously cute or we get it all
the time yes you hey hey bro I'm walking
my kid yeah aren't clearly not gay I go
son here you're cute
you know that's creepy I went no doubt
he is as cute as it gets
and then he goes yeah ah dude hey man I
got my [ __ ] kid here I in Tigers
holding this like train that he likes
Bush I sweat but it's good all right
let's go and then I have to give Tiger
went that you're gay man that doesn't
game there's nothing wrong with it gay
man that's a crazy man creepy man we're
gonna change up our you dad dad doesn't
go on a walk with a son and a dicksuck
yeah we're gonna get going you're cute
yeah but real lazy he killed
he's got a gun pressed against it come
on that's kind of creepy
you know he's a pet you know he's weird
because he had the match in like Russell
Athletic blue navy blue and bottom
matching you don't say like everything
the last time you saw someone wearing
that [ __ ]
unless you're in a like a private gym
class in school you don't have to wear
that the matching sweats when's the last
time you saw a grown adult wearing
matching sweats your dick dirty well
you're either you're either a gangster
you're either a Mafia don they don't
door or they don't even get anymore and
they will use you wear the adidas suits
at least for the felis you know this
[ __ ] had on grungy old Russell Athletic
navy blue top matching bottoms black and
some nope how to hear you why is he
black bro this is some white guy no he's
white as [ __ ] come on to your
neighborhood white guy a rodent come on
[ __ ] ain't it funny how as Nick
profiling better go I'm afraid of the
white guy
well so what for sure I was down two
kids and trying to take that it was
walking my dog in Chelsea one time his
young man I was probably my 20s and cute
and I was the morning and I was I had my
pitbull there and a guy comes up and
he's like nice dog man and I noticed he
was wearing sweatpants you know the kind
of the cloths what Manson you can see a
man's dick you see his dong and his dong
and I was like all right feel like
there's no like yet not yet he was just
a kind of oh he was just sitting there
you know just sitting maybe maybe there
was definitely some blood flow but I
couldn't tell the hot day so he's like
yeah man you got a dog huh I bet you
could with that dog and I was like all
right and his hair was a little I was
like all right this guy's just a little
off and he's like yeah man you've been
up you you wake up you early riser and I
go huh not not not usually bro now I'm
down now I'm already no no the nine
freehub body senses yeah and also don't
run the [ __ ] murky and don't don't
[ __ ] try to Bulldog me and alpha me
man because I'll [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know me I'm insecure
I get macho pitbull yeah yeah and this
guy's little bigger than me too so I'm
already like alright so he goes uh he
goes yeah
you got kids and I go no wait wait for
so I can't get I go now here's what you
waiting for
I bet you gotta you guys what though
yeah yep you guys you guys I bet you had
some good kids man I'm looking at you
kids now I look down and he's just tena
well he's not ten-hut but just the the
back of his dong because it's bent over
you understand oh he has that spider
monkey tail ya be up here that's a it
was bent down yeah just whales don't go
straight they go kind of gon try to
impress me Oh gonzo yep he had a gonzo
nose here swag
yeah gonzo did the gonzo no sweat he had
Ghassan those sweats that's a great
that's a great way to put it and he's
gonzo knows of me right now he's not
know God and any Regency now I'd rather
have it full erect oh god he's creepy
was a lazy heavy gonzo nose and he
reached down just kind of a justice man
you'd be along he hanging out we doing I
got non-believing so [ __ ] out of here
bro how strange is see you like I called
you after don't know if you remember
this I was going on a run I ran up down
Santa Monica right where it's almost on
the the hill there what looks down on
the beach I'm rather in the sky with
this giant German Shepherd and again
dude was in sweats watch [ __ ] people
in sweats and he goes hey looking for a
dog man and this is what the time when I
was I went yeah I'll see em and it was
like this big-ass German Shepherd is
yeah I can always tell oh my god that's
strange we start talking back and forth
and he's like just you like you like to
run a lot of my gap run a little bit
yeah how many miles usually do you look
like do some modeling yeah for sure
anyways and starts going he goes yeah I
know Mark Coleman I'm like no doubt
that's cool man have a good day and he's
like yeah hold on you so do you wanna
you want a dog I'm like maybe you know
of all the corralling us yeah for sure
man he keeps going similar to sting yeah
I'm like oh he wants something yeah if I
want someone my [ __ ] yeah or my mouth
you want something while his dog like
sits in the corner and watches you want
your mom then I just go he goes you look
around here man I'm not I've ran far man
I'm
I'm back that way so how I could tell my
my dick sensor went off my oh no see
your dick sensor yeah see a man I go to
leave Nia's bra let me get your number
so let me get your number I swear
aggressive no I did I don't want hurt
his feelings I go yeah yeah why not why
not and I gave him the first part of my
number and then switch up the whole back
yeah and then he goes I'm gonna call you
right now just so you have mine there
you go
I just text me man you know I'm sure I
got it cuz you wanted me to get my phone
out did you know that's a guy who
relentlessly see there are certain guys
that want to get banged and those guys
are way less aggressive it's the dudes
that that would that are gonna [ __ ] you
like I was in broke in Sheppard that was
from the game of Thrones I don't saw the
shirt today
yeah from the game of thrones hit with
one of those big wolf's the the giant
one yeah him and that giant game of
Thrones German Shepherd trying to [ __ ]
yeah that's a Santa Monica that's a dog
that he could SiC on you if you don't if
you don't that's why you don't have a
fake number yeah yo man let me get him
row it yeah see why not big dark 7 to
you baby round and thick he's trying to
[ __ ] and wanted that back you might how
about how about and I said duly and
Brian this I got this I snap shot this
dude slitting my dm's and it goes damn
you find that's like six months ago
three months ago yo man you should post
a picture with your pants off I
obviously don't allow these or see them
yeah then yesterday yo I would suck you
dry you should let me suck your dick so
I snapshot that 10 - dili and Brian go
howdy I think I'm thinking about it
cause I know I suck you dry
god damn it those are aggressive dudes
man those are aggressive dudes there's
something about like I was at Gold's Gym
and I was doing MADtv and I'm the one on
calls which is basically a gay bar with
like which one which gold the one on
coal it used to be like he'd seen twos
just roided-up there's no disease they
were dressed in camo and one dude would
be sitting on the other ones hips as
he's doing calf
they were spot in each other guys with
pierced nipples and just get it ranked
tops it was fantastic it was just shaved
chests oil smells like coconut everybody
was orange fantastic [ __ ] you
good-looking girls well I won't know you
know the truth is they've got everyone
they weren't trying to [ __ ] me because
they were they were so muscular Frank
will use to work out there was when
Frank was 200 pounds and so it was all
like models and I had frames a hot girl
in the gym cuz there's it's really nice
we got Gold's even a box where you know
they're a good-looking girl like okay
let's relax everyone like yeah no one's
trying to [ __ ] you relax well you you
are when you walk in you know gay men
are gonna me we even back then I was a
little skinny they they they were other
guys but this guy took a shine to me as
I'm doing my my [ __ ] tricep pushdown
somebody tomatoes as they say from
Shawshank the ladies took a liking to
you yeah need to frame yeah and what a
gold you it late I'm I'm trying to be
shitty I know you think you're muscular
and all that I'm nothing when you walk
into gold I'm nothing
yeah need to frame stop working out
there now I'm red I'm red yeah Andy
percent no it's [ __ ] with red no but
yeah I need to frame I'm meet and I like
I'd like to say you fought them boys off
all the time sometimes sometimes
sometimes sometimes because guess what I
wasn't [ __ ] with these guys they
you're a hundred percent right as I'm
doing my pull-downs a guy gets get syrup
right behind me bumps my knees with his
knees he goes get your knees down get
those in here why as I could feel his
but his breath on my neck come on come
on give me one more and I'm like just
very [ __ ] weird my triceps are
[ __ ] burning and I felt weird as his
knees are bumping on my knees and he's
like I told you when I did this without
the antenna at this train I assumed he
liked the weather they taste yeah and
we're doing something I was like I think
and he goes he goes you've done weight
Paulson yeah all the time I love those
years yeah you ever done like dynamic
weight
pull-ups I'm like I mean it's dynamic
you can get with a pattern you know
weight around your waist
hanging Darius now I got some pretty
good crouch down and he gets like we're
playing [ __ ] chicken in the pool I
thought my shoulders dick on the back of
my neck
gonzo nose on the back of my neck deal
I'm doing boy you're doing and they're
all he don't make sense
now as I would pull and he would lift up
like this yeah just this fat nutsack on
the back of my now I could it was like
Jack laughing of course he was he was
pressing against your thick [ __ ]
Denver neck come on 10 more 10 more 10
more oh my guns and burrows about your
neck
get your [ __ ] healthy dick off of my
neck you super healthy yeah yeah yeah
that's when somebody gets on your
shoulders can I get you want to do
dynamic pull-ups guys will come up with
a [ __ ] time and Maitlis [ __ ] you mean
put your dick on back when I try to pull
ups no well not really cuz you're just
doing muscle ups and then I'm just doing
the movement and your [ __ ] you [ __ ] your
[ __ ] the folds in my neck what's gone
you just [ __ ] my neck yeah and I think
I paid you for this price every woman
will tell you that on the subway in New
York City every single woman there's
always a guy who's like whoops it's
crowded in here
yawns oh sorry I gotta put my push my
beard I'm brushing your teeth that's
tech stroke I'm mixing this texture I
take throwing this yesterday there's
this guy who I see in the gym hopeful
and he's homeless so hopefully well if
he doesn't spot cash out to this guy
he's crazy I've seen a lot of freaks in
my lifetime through sports
I never seen someone like this French
homeless guy I catch him the gym once
every three months they at dissident
boxing he just in the weight room and he
comes in he lifts in jeans and I sweat
in a rolled-up cutoff sweatshirt like
he's from [ __ ] pumping iron arnold
serial killer mitten long hair French
and just he's [ __ ] jack right doesn't
eat many meals but just genetics and he
talks himself in a hole here's this
French accent so it makes even creepier
and he's so goddamn strong and I would
just stare actually wanted one of those
crazy strong I want one of the things he
was using when the these things do these
Paulette so I was too scared to ask him
he's gonna bite me rip my face off but
he he gets on the bench and he just goes
oh yes yes yes oui oui oui oui all you
want you want to start you want to stop
no no unit stop you not stop wait burn
now it burning it burned a why you stop
you ain't stopping
you ain't stop it you got 20 more you
got 20 more you got this tire himself
yes yes yes yes thing drops it in her go
and sis it's what you want to do it's
what you want to do you hear just what
you want to do you do this gets a friend
who do this you want to do this he's
talking about he goes yeah they look but
it's like he's just in there by himself
yeah it'll go this go heavier we go have
for you you wanna go ahead here he's
having this conversation with himself
and he goes what's he happiest you live
have you grabs the Bible know where he
found them cuz I'm always looking for
heavier weights goes doesn't goes all
right this one dude now and then he'll
do that and they went to cable and I
mean while I pretend I'm working out but
I have my headstone course not working
just listen or to do just cuz it gives
and then he also has his entire belongs
with him in a in a rollaway bag oh yeah
obviously not all there he gets on the
crossover machine he's gone he's crazy
strong though stupid strong really
weights stronger than me what waste Ron
it's very dangerous
no diet and up just why really it gets
done and goes yes yes big guy then I'm
getting a big train huh yeah he looks
like shrinker and I had a baby and
friends well that's very sparring guys
that but not like breaded
just like he looks like the juggernaut
from x-men but French his [ __ ] that is
that easy we Harry and then he takes out
this comas pocket they said in the whole
time and his jeans and his goddamn jeans
that he works out and no belt just keeps
pulling his pants up and then nope then
he gets done I see him just staring out
the window and he has long hair longer
than mine nice here and I said
good-looking guy how old would take mad
scientist but Jay Howell
must be 50 all gray here think of
Einstein if he's on a crazy deca like
cycle he looks like I got a story for
you so then he just he's staring at the
traffic and he has his comb and it's
going yes yeah so yes ask Tony I go dude
that guy's creased not he's nice like he
doesn't bother anyone he comes in there
and [ __ ] puts in work what excuse do
you have not to Train he's homeless
doing work no protein powder no [ __ ]
alpha brain he's just [ __ ] monster
steroids
no he's just as big freak Jesus and
there so he just combs his hair to be
that big dip strong and also Crazy's vas
carry guys Tony I go dude and he goes he
somehow gets the money together to come
in here and pay for the you might have
taken care of him you know somebody has
like this one luggage with him I just
he's fasting I'd like to talk to him I
like I said I'm scared he's gonna a bite
me with this horrible French teeth and
rip a part of my neck off yeah or just
he's so goddamn juggernaut strong assume
like huh
what did you say huge face oh yeah takes
your face off life over that's so weird
because you see because you might have
he might have the strength machine palsy
I'm telling you my monkey [ __ ] yeah you
need to talk to him but the thing is is
for him I don't know if it if anyone
works out
imagine you a set of 20 with the
heaviest dumbbells you can do for 20 and
talking the entire time no interest yes
yes well they want you to stop there's
no stopping there's a hotdog
Wow it's fascinating I want to put it on
my camera by didn't wanna like it's
privacy I'm not making fun of them now
I'm celebrating this [ __ ] genetic
freak from France who's clearly he's
either crazy or he's just awesome maybe
he's lost yeah just sometimes people I
think I want to be friends with them
because he was using something I want to
use but my god man what if he's like
like just flies off the Hamill's on me
usually I don't know more by myself yeah
I think that what's he having that
like that are generally hopefully
harmless they're just they're just I
think he's harmless
yeah I don't want be the other triggers
of no no it's a little scary that's
scary you know even a small person if
they're pleased he's fascinating I see
him in there once every few months
telling us yeah he took no problems come
to us work tips out didn't talk to
anyone
mmm man I'd love to talk to him to see
what his story yeah you just want it he
has glasses they can be sued yeah
and the speech that like some of us to
conversations that have you know with
himself it's pretty interesting like
good vocabulary like not a dumb like not
like a big Green Mile type of dumbass
you know saying like he's not like a
[ __ ] there's a guy's a guy like that in
my neighborhood he's not like the giant
guy from Game of Thrones watching over
that kid there's a woman in my
neighborhood who I walk by her I was
walking my dogs she was in a Toyota or
something or Honda Civic and she's like
looking down and I'm like what's she
doing she's looking down like really
intensely and I walked and I walked by
that's weird so I come back she's still
looking down and I go oh she's nodding
off she fell asleep
well no she was like and I look at her
oh she's an addict she's yeah I feel
real good and now I see her periodically
she'll Park her car like certain areas
in this neighborhood and she's just yeah
she's just your neighborhood and then I
saw her the other day like getting high
I said she had all the stuff with her
and it was just like and then she just
got him and yeah I didn't see her
shooting I saw their usually pretty good
well I didn't yeah but I saw her kind of
detailin and she was just like I was
like oh they're doing this situation
here was in her car don't let her get
high yeah if the school would call the
cops
well it's around a neighborhood it is
near a school it's actually do right by
us weblogs
yeah but like there's this weird like
schizophrenic mom who was sleeping
outside
because I live across from an elementary
school kindergarten elementary and it
was like half an hour before the kid
starts I'll walk my son around there and
he was just like you know [ __ ] with
the things yeah I had to tell someone
had to tell the cops up the street got
to get him he can't have kids around
that who knows yeah I'm always worried
about a guy in a [ __ ] van driving
around or something like that what they
still use I don't know if answer that
like we we have the misconception that
vans are still the creepy guys trying to
[ __ ] kids I don't think they're
advancing more cuz the gigs up the gigs
up like no-one's looking for a 88 van
yeah like Chevy van anymore now you know
I don't know what the serial killers
[ __ ] yeah like who knows what they're in
now they have a lot of different play
tesla's they got a lot of different
techniques as well as well Tesla's this
horrible transition especially have
talking about horrible people but how
about Ralphie may path annoy yeah
Ralphie such a shame Ralphie was a a
delicate man he was a really sweet sweet
guy and a huge fan of comedy and a huge
fan of his of his colleagues and people
like though in what's but not funny it
was a bad use of words but Jay Tex - man
how about Ralphie May and Jay remembers
him because when we were doing the
Austin Tommy Festival the moon tower
festival before I went on Jay and a long
conversation with him we're on the same
plane with him yeah we're the same plane
but then when we're out there I did a
show and he was you know obviously the
headliner and he was a guy who was suit
I don't I don't know Ralphie really we
had some conversations but he's always
super supportive with me which in the
comedy world a lot of people are
supportive than a lot of people I [ __ ]
that guy and Ralphie was it like [ __ ]
yeah guy no not at all
so I saw him like oh [ __ ] he was gonna
come to the podcast what a shame yeah
why and I and I hate to say this and I
don't mean in any way but I knew this
was coming you know it was only a
fortune everyone that knows him really
well who's just ourselves people I went
man [ __ ] how about Ralphie and people
like man kind of saw this one coming
yeah everybody saw it was just the thing
I know tell was trouble such a good guy
what's troublesome is he has two kids
two daughters which that [ __ ] sucks
the other thing is quite a few months
ago
I was at the laughs right before I went
on it oh how is it they went Ralphie
fell asleep on stage or something like
that not at off on stage yeah I think he
I think they were there were there was
medication involved he was a guy who was
such as always dealing with that problem
yeah man but but but left left left
behind a lot of great comedy and
everybody liked him and he was always
really nice to everybody had a bad news
on the burning to everybody he was just
a really beautiful guy and I yeah and
Marc Maron just released his podcasts
did with Ralphie May like I think from
2012 it's pretty cool to listen to yeah
he just came to LA you know one last
comic standing in 2010 it's pretty cool
to listen
I remember Ralphie though doing god I
think it was Dublin's probably 12 years
ago Ralph it was a young guy doing
stand-up I'm killing it back then they
say moved out here in the theatre's
sleep on J Morris floor he's about 17 or
18 yeah I remember I remember literally
probably 15 years ago Ralphie was was
was killing crowds I mean he was funny
as [ __ ] monster yeah monster I'm gonna
watching his specials yeah super monster
always funny always great always working
always touring I just started listening
to mark Mary again I kind of fell off
the went back to it because he had that
Davidson from Saturday Night Live yeah
Tommy Davidson no no no that's a black
guy from this is Davidson
he's on certain life he was a comic he
got the gig by doing stand-up he's like
I don't I don't I don't do characters
I'll do any sketch but his comedy was so
good you know Lauren Michaels gave him a
shot at life right and he's so young he
was saying how he didn't know what the
show was he was like I know it from you
to because I knew from I think he's 24
so it's amazing that if he goes he goes
I knew sketches Will Ferrell did and I
didn't I just thought there will ya Pete
Davidson he goes I just knew it as I
thought it was Will Ferrell bits I
didn't know it was on sale I thought but
I did I did my research anyways made up
begin the show and he talks about
unmark man how he struggles with
horrible depression like awful
depression and that's what brought me
back to mark man but then I liked more
than the speed Dave's the guy he's
fascinating man I saw him around the
Comedy Store a few times yeah
and but what's funny is with is the
depression I think it's good when people
speak on it because I think so many
people are going through it when someone
like this sells says they struggle with
it doesn't sound like life they did a
bit about it and it's because it when
him gone Marc Maron going blast she was
the worst year of my life in though you
think you'd be killing it he was yeah
where she in my life my girlfriend how
she puts up with me all this stuff and
so obviously it's in the headlines all
that stuff so Senate live this this past
Saturday they did a bit where he's dead
honest about depression cuz you know you
should probably see a doctor
you see a doctor and they might be I'll
help you with medication and you know
and the other thing is is if your cast
my silent life play my goddam sketches
more often
that could bring happiness and the guys
like well yeah man it's tough because I
know it's like an eight hour show
there's fifty segments you could do a
some just to help my sanity so twenty
healthy flippers knocking awesome yeah I
don't know yeah that mental health stuff
is dad died in September 11th so he has
an issue have I talked about this before
no I knew there he has an issue where so
his dad right he was a firefighter goes
I'll be right back go September up die
so now he struggles with whenever
someone goes I'll be right back whether
it's a friend girlfriend ye off see
that's why wait [ __ ]
so he's dealing with that I can't
imagine yeah there's a book that
everybody should read called Extremely
Loud and Incredibly Close Tom Hanks
turning into a movie written by I think
Jonathan Safran Foer who was a genius
wrote it when he was 28 years old and
one of the things about a 12 year old
boy I think he's even younger but who
loses his dad in 9/11 it is a phenomenal
book [ __ ] the other movie omits
I didn't see the movie I just the walk
is like a masterpiece [ __ ]
masterpiece
kids young to 23 years old she said I
live this is like its third season to oh
say that's impressive
crazy right that's a talented they're
talking about Wow they're they're asking
new sketches like I just I can't do my
you don't know what to do let's attack
here's I subdued use I can do myself
yeah who's they
ask me they go you look just like this
guy try and he goes let's Pete Davidson
trying to do this because I don't know
what to tell you it's not for me scale
well sketch is is it takes a long time
was this acting no every one of the
sketch guys is there is an actor I mean
they studied it for a long time not easy
man and it's actually a lot of the great
sketch comedians are in their 30s it
takes a long time so some people are
good at it you know just off like they
have a knack for yeah characters they're
doing characters but some people's just
not you're thinner brilliantly talked
about you is not somebody it's not what
I do it's not sure now anyway he's
twenty [ __ ] three things might change
believe me you know you'll get a handle
on [ __ ] I hope he came out and uh
Tycho's depression though you never
think I don't know you know this Kelly
Brogan did she's a psychiatrist to deal
with the worst cases like people that
scratch holes in their face I got this
thing in my face and they just keep
scratching me she deals with that and
she wrote a book called to mind of her
own that my wife read and and then if
you listen to her on Rogan she was one
of these I think said her name was -
Kelly Brogan Kelly Brogan on Rogan yeah
Kelly Kelly Brogan featured on Rodia
Kelly Brogan on Rogan and she she would
always deal with the worst cases but
what she would deal with this because
she was a doctor she would prescribe
certain medications because that's what
you did you you just look at somebody
and go you you haven't you're taking
birth control pills okay that means that
you're messing with your hormones you
should take some antidepressants as well
because it'll [ __ ] with your head you're
taking you have whatever it is and she'd
get these hardcore cases will put you on
this that and the other thing they just
started realize hold on you know there
are a lot of factors that contribute to
depression like you could have a messed
up thyroid for whatever reason could
even be the way you're eating and
exercising not sleeping enough there are
a lot of reasons yes of course it is
some people are both she deals with
severe depressions to wit but by the way
this is one person's account so you're
right you have to take this you have to
be careful but but one of the things
that she's found is that she's gotten a
lot of traction and a lot of the
you know helped a lot of people with
very serious depression without a lot of
these drugs diet exercise diet exercise
sleep patterns circadian rhythm all this
kind of solitary hill earth so it stops
each time out then that some what's the
street appeal I think it's not right I
mean it depends for some people but also
some people don't know a lot about it
mmm they know a good amount but for some
people it's like well you have a shitty
job your girlfriend cheated on you are
you losing your kids your me depressed
man I'm not clinically depressed you
just you're sad it's normal people go
through it but then like look II know he
had a whole life fat like everything was
great and he still kill himself like
like Peterson talks about he goes you
know and he's met with a lot of people
because I didn't know what it was he was
I was born I've always been I was born
like this man yes my serotonin that's my
father passed away I was genetically
born like that's right people are your
serotonin levels can be at for me
they're probably between 7 and a 10 I'm
just lucky I'm always I have good
chemicals running through my brain and I
feel generally positive there are people
and I know them and they're talented or
whatever alone they just have their
serotonin levels are usually at a four
or five you know if you could measure it
I mean they're just even if they win the
lottery and they cure you know every
disease in the world they're still going
to be there their looks we've been going
to act in entertainments people go you
got to have some sort of that darkness
or stuff like that to be creative yeah
and you know how I first started going
in this I thought the same thing but
when I thought about I thought wool is
it just that there's not a huge pool to
take from cuz there's a lot of people
with the present stuff who aren't
creative and then there's a lot of
people that's fan don't have any
creative but they're actually successful
- but you're sampling from a pool not
everyone's [ __ ] up re-create a pee-pee
there are creative people out there some
not all or some some are not depressed
at all and some you know devote
basically produce a lot of stuff
throughout their lifetime then there are
people that are very creative and happen
to also suffer from depression
yes just like they're very creative
motivation can link them now there are
very creative musicians musicians and
some go on to create huge bodies of work
like the Beatles like Zeppelin like
Springsteen like
you too and we just keep going on and on
who don't who didn't succumb to drugs
they might have done a couple of myself
weed but for the money gone through a
phase but for the most part can was I
didn't do drugs I likes it right yeah
and then there are really talented
people that also have substantive very
tell me one house that's substance abuse
problems yeah Amy Winehouse according to
people who knew her said that she was
she was somebody who suffered from
mental illness and was also prodigiously
talented and she probably would have
been that way regardless of the music
the music didn't make her crazy she was
an ordinary crazy my family suffered
from mental illness yeah right I mean
and we don't yet know the details of
what mental illness is there are lots of
theories have you ever taken me of that
like zola for no cuz I never have you
guys [ __ ] with it
MJ nothing yeah me too and they swear by
it
gin da are you don't take any so I think
natural stuff but you don't take any
subscriptions or anything that first
good sorry like blood pressure stuff
yeah hi blue are these in my family yeah
I don't really do religiously you do
have mmm-hmm interesting you don't you
don't take anything I'm too young a [ __ ]
[Music]
get on that micro she just a little
black target on then no I did
birth control they've been like starting
that this year but it's I'm like totally
[ __ ] up my hormones yes and then
taking a pill or did you Apache um just
because of like it wasn't even for yeah
just the this the pill just like level
up my hormones because it was irregular
and I know it's kinda like TMI but my
girlfriend she's taking birth control
and she was taking depression meds and
she was like high and low like she'd be
like appear happy and then all sudden
she'd be like dark depressed don't read
that book because Kelly Brogan deals
with this a lot and talks about it and
she does women and she's been practicing
medicine for a long time also tell her
talk to her doctor about well cuz birth
control to you to find the right one
like there's different levels where sure
was that yeah according to Kelly Brogan
there's also a doctor and a medical
license doctor has worked with it a lot
of doctors just don't know cuz they're
not up on the research so you know you
do your own research too
because there are doctors that know and
there are doctors that don't it's just
about talk to your doctor - it's me you
know I'm gonna talk to you doctor no I
mean like I'm good now like I'm fine
with that like um but I know like a lot
of girls are struggling with like
finding the right birth control and like
supplements - I've heard like
supplements I don't know like for sure
but I've heard supplements can [ __ ] with
like your birth control - for sure yeah
so you can actually avoid them
yeah some people take too many vitamins
like I have a lot of hippie friends that
are like oh I'm so healthy I take this
this this this and this I'm like that's
way too much like at one time for money
like you're overdoing it you know one of
the top surgeons in for women's so for
endometrial cancers and you Ryan cancers
and things one of the top surgeons who
in fact is the guy who uses robotics on
women's stuff he said they they use
robots robotics so now they'll have a
they'll have a robot with four hands
that'll do all he's controlling the West
yeah it's so precise and he believes
it's a little off the record but he says
to his patients don't drink kombucha and
why and he goes we haven't done enough
of the studies yet but there's something
about the fermentation that causes that
is causing certain cancers in women and
what what's going on he goes we don't
have all the documentation of the
measurements yet but I as a surgeon I as
a surgeon have been doing this for a
very long time and let me tell you this
is my private bit yeah I'm in the
trenches I'm in the trenches I'm telling
you that I think there's a cause only
III look whether it's true or not I went
that's a scientist that's a doctor who
deals with women all the time I was like
what the [ __ ] man how about that and and
you know part of it is also that I don't
know if kombucha is bad for you I drink
it here and there I don't know look but
it's pretty interesting that you know a
lot of times when we're taken we're
taking all these supplements and we
don't quite know how they work with our
body and you're taking a bunch of
different things you better be careful
because you're messing with the
chemistry of your body so there's
there's a way I do it one by one like a
lot something into my routine and see if
it gives you migraines or if I see it
look to nauseous and then like slowly
filtered in yeah but there's definitely
way you can be too healthy my friend
said that you can actually develop a
cancer from taking too many supplements
- she works in a bio lab Johnson you get
a lot of problems here the skin
you can get a lot of problems doing so
well also when you when people take
massive amounts of antioxidants mm-hmm
sometimes I accidentally I guess they
also take out some of the or they
nullify some of the cancer-causing
agents proteins and things that's that's
that's another theory so you don't want
to be taken like somebody who's taken
like thirty five hundred milligrams I
think of vitamin E well it's like you
know like a lot of you take a lot of
that it's an antioxidant right you're
taking vitamin C that's the equivalent
of that's the equivalent of 1500 almonds
can you I don't think you're allowed to
take too much because you caught your
blood or not higher but if you take too
much see you will [ __ ] your pants yeah
take massive quantities of vitamin C
that yeah that was [ __ ] your pants yeah
chin you take no supplements I told you
kratom kratom is that a supplement I
mean like uh - like for recovery or
anything I use turmeric so I take
turmeric every day cuz it hurt it's like
a good anti-inflammatory I do - yeah and
I feel like I I want to take one I go to
sleep I feel like I'm less bloated if
that even makes turmeric is an
anti-inflammatory yeah that's probably
it
and then I have those blood pressure
pills that I take once in a while we've
never done creatine or protein I did
creating withdrawal
what I did creatine whites but it didn't
do anything for me because I didn't lift
weights yeah we gotta get you working on
the box burn guys there I was in there -
sworn like what's up with gin hey I've
been waiting come on man let's go yeah
by the way and I want to warn everybody
here like I'm gonna walk in periodically
and your first instinct is gonna go that
guy's core is stupid and that's cuz I've
been doing core work in the morning so
all I had a doctor reach out about TRT
he goes if Brian says one more time he
can't wait to get Jack from TRD goes I'm
gonna bust doctor he goes you guys need
it and I know how it works I just go
along with the bits but TR T's not gonna
make you jack no no so what happens this
way TR t words
so when let's say you get your levels
checked and they're like you didn't
you're not but let's say they go it's a
legit doctor by the way so so when you
go to legit doctors you say are you
loves at 300 right there only in get you
in the normal range okay so so to get
jacked yeah you're gonna have to be at
plus you know 1400 like I checked my
okay you're gonna have to be there oh
yeah huge amount yeah you're not you
might put on some lean muscle or have
more energy you might cut down on your
fat look like I need more you're not
gonna get like you're not gonna be
[ __ ] I'm knocked out no you do not
think mass amounts he goes dude I just
wear two got it if you guys say that one
more time I was like nah I get how he
works
it's just it'd be hilarious that's so
funny so so it's not the same it's so
when you take like decker winstrol
anything like that you're talking you're
boosting your test levels to here okay
that's where they get bloated purple
skin Jack put on mass amounts of muscle
TR T's just gonna get you so you feel
good and you got a normal human
functional level I wonder what the
female CrossFitters the professionals
are doing put Fitness woman in the world
on for a sec CrossFit because I wonder
what they're what they're taking first
of all they're in sick shape they're
already amazing athletes but there's no
doubt to meit's mean it's there's some
anabolics going on and I don't know it's
weird just to assume Wow
I'm saying to assume that I'm not an
expert in steroids I've no idea
I it's tough to know what men take a
little own women yeah and if you listen
to that documentary or watch that
documentary on Netflix or the guy who's
on Rogen who did the doc about the
Russians you're gonna assume most people
are yeah yeah there's no in the world
she's amazing I'll get a piss so hard
she trains in Olympics she I think she's
a nun in the Australian Olympic team and
she's such a [ __ ] athlete anyway
she's amazing she doesn't look like
she'd I don't know I mean you know I
think you know some of those girls are
so jacked like she's not a good example
oh that's a good example here yeah we
all know yeah
you don't nobody I'm I'm all dry but
thank you pal you go piss hard
you got a llama bottom in them pants huh
yeah we'll keep rolling man let's just
keep real were talking man do you think
I get bring up bring a Thorisdottir
Thorisdottir th ori s thor is daughter
Yeah right there she's she there she is
that's my girl she was the fittest woman
though she's from Iceland now take a
look at her for a second keep going
though just just keep like going through
it well yeah those are Vikings right
there she's beautiful though look at how
gorgeous whoa hold on now stop if you're
gonna tell me that's not ahead of Alex
look at the tummy on her I mean she's
already a very special specimen and a
freak athlete but that's clearly
anabolics you know you're not you're not
because if you look at the CrossFit
girls before all of this became like a
money game they were very fit and they
looked amazing but they weren't quite
this I mean the stomach muscles are
stupid I mean come on looks ridiculous
yeah yeah that's a different thing
that's that's you know she's already a
genetic freak but she's getting us
getting a little help there but you know
I have to say she's a beautiful woman
man what a badass bodybuilders are
insane yes I find I find women in shape
I like I like muscular women what's
ahead is the same as like the menswear
it's like the classic physique was at
the lifts there's different like types
are with what with with CrossFit no I'm
cross with bodybuilding and she's like
doing Olympic who's she's doing some
Olympic in the face yeah well so so
CrossFit has Olympic lifts in him they
use a lot of barbells and stuff okay
she's so painfully thick
Oh keep that up for for Brendan I want
him to see this blurry one no the one
that we were at where we were like what
the [ __ ] where she's carrying what she's
doing the farmers walk farmers carry
there you go she said now Brennan if you
want to take a look this is Annie
Thorisdottir who was absolutely she
wanted miss most I think she want it
twice in a row salivating over
that's a thick girl right there that's
very pretty on the left and then oh
that's the same girl yeah that's a
little help who knows yeah you're so
into those cross we could take at let's
take a different approach I am not quite
into that that I'm a little too lightly
asked for that but I'm very happy with
CrossFit women and the men and the men
yeah I don't know Jen yeah forward to
current events what's up with gender
dawg
Oh shaking up the chinder shirts dropped
this Wednesday along with a certified
dick diver sweet Wow what's going on
tinder did you go on a goddamn date went
on a date what last night
details yeah how much can I say without
getting it she's very pretty
oh why you sent a picture cuz we we had
a live set of video together we had a
whole thread with all the song very
pretty because I posted a picture of a
skeleton sitting on a bench I know I put
this me waiting for a chin to go on a
date and then you sent a picture of the
girl and she first of all would you meet
this die me they're friends really yeah
what ethnicity is she this is mom
getting really worried me
she's yummy nummies no no so that's
another thing she's not she's not the
one I told you about before Anna SHhhh
she's a hundred percent Asian okay but
how's that gonna give her a weight on
America god I did this show is too
freaking yeah popular by the way so
either way she's awesome
we hung out wherever we're just out the
longest in Koreatown
so that should probably give it away so
she's grant that's actually a clause
that was her idea to go to Koreatown but
it's my idea would it kill you to get
her out of Koreatown but kill you to
take her down take her down to kill me
no scopa they take her down to woman but
that's what she was comfortable it
sounds good cuz you could vote you go
eat you drink and you go karaoke is that
what that got such a good night is that
what you guys did we did so you reckon
late
hold up chin break this down for us this
is a big deal on for you it is huge deal
you look good where thank you yeah she I
mean
that means doctor for a little bit
dirtier no well here's the thing so
Sunday night yes I do it not Saturday no
because I have wedding remember yes so
you said let's do Sunday night and then
how did you go pick her up at her place
you meet their house man we met at a
place called the line lion the line
behind yeah you met at the hotel drinks
for drinks
the only ones here do you uh
Bill Cosby no so did you uh did you so
you got there
yeah and then does she listen to the
show would you guys talk about no she
doesn't
I don't if she listens she's aware she's
aware cuz she does follow me on
Instagram so she knows what she knows
yeah she knows of me and she knows my
friends so and she is a solid job she
does she's I'm so hard I'm a fan I'm a
fan oh yeah I'm looking I'm a liking
little surprised I thought it's
Photoshop for a second there yeah hot at
all no not a video a video a very crap
crack to rock you made her laugh in the
video charming I didn't do anything I
was in can lie on he can sneak and he
can make you laugh you were stone face
in the video oh we are serious you're
serious
Asian giant what were you talking about
though chin I feel this is where you
struggle you know I'm saying we're hung
out yeah dude we talk about everything
we know what to talk about the way we're
drinking to so it's just interesting so
much I'm really hungover right now it's
a little out of it I have like stains on
my shirt you're in the same clothes
yes hey bro hey I might smell if you've
been out all night and you wearing the
same clothes you didn't go home what
time do you what time did you raged
she's a good girl she didn't do anything
what times you raged till Jack dude we
actually went we went hey bro man it's a
lot of [ __ ] going hey dude that gonzo
knows first of all first I'm a lonely
Cal first of all he shirt sobbing it's
all canto IV I'm hot right now I bet
you're talking about this bro he's in
the same clothes no no all my a boozing
aha boozing ah but she's no nothing
happened like that though
no not like I ask you a question did you
wish she didn't curry she didn't uh hang
out at my hotel I'll say I wish she
didn't stay the night
well if you got a hotel room I did get a
hotel around this I had to make it
official [ __ ] yeah you got a hotel room
that place of the line so we did go back
to the hotel and then hung out for a
while and then we went to go eat again
at like 3:00 in the morning long night
chin up makes also but you that's when
you like a girl when you're willing here
I she didn't get honest and I'm good no
she's actually cool do you guys eat
cream barbecue soon uh very close Korean
food but there I wish you guys would go
so yeah good then you went to I'm never
having so then you went to uh come on
yeah Maru we'll go to war I'll take you
tomorrow
yours attack don't ever put your hands
like that it's on Washington and and
Lincoln it's Nam water you never even
know what a white guy from New York I
listen to turnout in Korea but but I'm
saying you don't want to drive that far
I know you won't but but there's a place
it's called how do I can't believe you
have them into what do how have you not
been there like so let's go there now
you know you know it's like Game of
Thrones forever
because everyone's like yeah you gotta
watch it us it made me not want to do it
that time with Korean barbeque back to
ginger I don't know why you're gonna
love it though okay I'm sure I will
Jay loves it Jade want wishes use Asian
or blacks like the he done counting this
hey so uh dinner drinks do you went to
karaoke
very oaky then backs yeah I like karaoke
before you can show off the Volia
I had to do for sure shut off the old
folks they need to flex that muscle or
that the vocal muscles yeah
what song did you get that [ __ ] with
yeah what song oh your go-to cuz I know
you I do have a go dude you were this
one good night Ida can't you give me
that yeah hit it Kevin I can't sing
right now no I can't do it we drinking
all my wouldn't come on I cannot give it
to me what all right
Oh what's this hot tea for my vocals
okay do get your heart too hot tienen
and an egg white for my vocals Oh what
is that squirt 11 - okay I guess I'll
get up there
mimimi what song catch almost ricotta my
bedtime by Usher how's that going how's
that go I don't know it's a cheesy
bedtime just sing one oh good good see
one you play a subversive a yeah for
sure
that was your go to bed time for my sure
it's my favorite thing I seen and you
guys were all drunk and you just started
seeing this bed times and it's he's very
very expensive to
kirok is expensive because it's you
drink and you eat in there too it's like
a whole thing we should there's a this
is more up-tempo that time that's
another thing playing oh ah I was like
that's way too much yeah no I imagine
chin going no I curl I don't give me
that shirt yeah I should just sing girl
I appreciate you come out tonight we
create a good time I've been waiting all
goddamn night what say all night I mean
about ten years for the wearing my
checkered shirt right now now I feel
pressured because my friends Oh chin
tried to [ __ ] are you trying to feel our
hearts on us go Jack oh you can sing huh
[Music]
Wow this would not be my go-to Oh a real
popular song cuz you know on YouTube
this songs been out for at Fir there's
only a hundred thousand views yeah but
that's acts so when you're like it's
actually better Ryan knows it so she
can't compare you yeah sure she knows
it's uh sure he doesn't know the [ __ ]
me hey let them have their date bro he's
trying to sing right now but you can
stop this gym for we at ban this was
your goat this was your first song I
forgot what the first one was and not
just cracks in my broken heart which I'm
sure you guys don't know man you got all
you got all do you get it on face and
sing get in her face and sing these
tunes no that's too cheesy
so he's awkward so much announcer but
then he's seen next to them and then
kind of look oh [ __ ] no let's you were
gone sewed up and your pants super gonzo
tow I knew it yeah and what should what
did she sing I wish I could be there I
really don't remember the stuff that
she's saying she's saying really well
though she and sing too
she sinks something we got don't funny
and sure think I was gonna say you're
gonna have a bunch of the gym it's who
can sing their ass off sounds like a pop
group in the word uh-huh uh-huh and you
got your white dancer so where'd you
guys leave it at when are you gonna see
her again
yeah of course oh damn yeah there goes
Channel yeah full-blown girlfriend
no no hey job well done let me get some
get those tinder shoes yeah guys
celebrate hey drop this Wednesday let's
celebrate chin getting guns was a test a
good man Oh Brian oh yeah everyone
equality control greenie huh let's take
it uh karaoke but shut the door it's
just called quality control that's all
it is what do you want - hey what what
what song would we sing to her to kind
of you know just let her know what we're
all about probably let me you can't
always get what you want this time you
can
oh maybe this time you can't always get
what you want
what does it have to be just Korean for
you how about - who white guys do white
guys that's the same you know 1634 huh
what what if the end but if not what
about an old under you know that under
pressure song under pressure Japan Arab
with my brains on the floor that's that
I just have it be a great song it's so
hard to sing ah daddy I wish I could say
Oh screaming let me uh that's such a
great song that might be my favorite
song of all time yeah you know and by
the way not a bad not a bad song to say
that about because it's my needle so
pointless
you never can you do that I will just
Enric like okay hated Bowie and and and
not this one Freddie more song another
pressure with crane and David Bowie
right just do that first one cuz this
one the first one I'd say that's watch
live that's what this is the one where
uh vanilla ice sued them or he sued
vandalizing watch watch framer this is
number one for me Brian hey there's
primary and I've been balls deep into
Bolton's these days I want you to
picture me in my slingshot gonna PCH
they're blown in the wind
look at him watch this look at Freddie
look at ready she's look at him prom
[Music]
now imagine me and Brian half mass we're
in soon good intake tops your girls sit
in front of us look at Bowie hey man
now his girls in front of us and she's
under pressure which is worth we're gone
sold up quality control Americanists
welcome to quality control time don't
know what's that what is it buddy mom's
old time - gonzo knows let's get a rope
gotta run our gonzo knows overall
merchants because these things have
sensors for irregularity just what Gon's
was about to bus ready to blow his nose
you know with gonzo bus it means if you
pass it means there are no
irregularities time for a gonzo nose
screaming check for irregularities not
at it oh my god what a great night look
at what--he's we're amazing it's so gay
and so awesome anyways cheering long
story short we'd like to [ __ ] your girl
do this on you stop before you Duff I
love what a great song I now hear I hear
that I just came outta my slingshot on
the PCH I'm in a tank top you know I was
blasted thing yep I don't give you were
blasting white your dog know that sound
yeah and just cruise it I mean he he had
a voice beyond like an angel oh man I
feel like we should do that for karaoke
there's a place in Hollywood I think
it's called you know I know I'm both the
80s baby so I feel like something dragon
not Double Dragon that was a phenomenal
phenomenal video game it's something
dropped maybe with a white dragon but
they have VIP rooms where there's like
food alcohol and then you have your own
rooms cuz you wanna be out in the public
and see I'm doing charity tonight the
canyon flow I'm driving one hour to do a
charity for free um but so you're gonna
see her again aren't you yeah I'm proud
of you man I mean could you have done it
without our help
honestly I work there and yeah for sure
kiddo for sure but you met her I feel
like we met this on tinder you met her
on tinder no no no okay difference but
here's the thing this is where Brian and
Big B here helped you
I don't know if you would have taken the
leap and got gone now you're right pants
if we didn't kind of apply the pressure
and also put the bat gonzo signal out
there Jinzo look it huh can you imagine
when he starts working out you start
tightening things up from the neck down
what you gonna be a giant agency actor
woman uh throwing your his he's me the
cream Chris Hemsworth
fucking-a right you Thor you got Danny
mention your Thor your Godzilla they do
it does your girl know she's [ __ ]
with the Korean Chris Hemsworth you
thought dude you would start working out
I mean you're already a good-looking guy
but when you start working out they get
all kinds of tight and you can sing
smart all that [ __ ] forget it it's game
over it's all she wrote I might start
dating you I might make a run at it but
we gotta run quality control with the
gonzo noses oh she's got a check for
everybody that knows the nose on earth
Heywood knows the nose is talking to the
mic girl
um would you ever go on a triple date
would you buy are you afraid to bring
around me and Brian here triple date me
if you guys bring your girls yeah solo
we got an MJ we got the blow and the
cash
if MJ's there's different then we're
looking to spend mm-hmm yeah let's all
get drunk and see where we end up so
you're gonna see her again in the
wedding went good Jin's life is
fascinating he could be a Korean
assassin yeah it's all it's all have no
idea secrets I have no idea
we don't know anything you don't even
live in Koreatown I saw that picture the
girl so I believe it for a second of
those Photoshop I'm in Korean that's a
mask who knows he might even be Chris
Hemsworth and how those singing thing go
out the wedding would you have the
busiest weekend ever
not really wedding in a dick so uh you
just sang the song in a way great huh
is there any video of it I'm sure some
people take video of it please how to uh
tag firing the kid if you got the video
at the wedding so we can see him
actually perform there's plenty of
footage of me singing online at weddings
I'm pretty sure we're I'll find it for
you the next time
all right that what MJ what'd you do
this weekend chilled school as usual a
lot of people reaching out to step to
our last podcast just uh hook you up
with them yes we've never had what we've
never had J I'll take all right no
everything like that's not her problem
Oh her little I whatever gives a [ __ ]
about that some really cool feedback
actually like a lot of our fans that are
girls we're reaching out to love it
right now yeah I'm looking at you right
now
we've been over the speed we do it hey
quiet you don't need to keep it quiet if
you had a dick
I'd be like I'll just push to the side
why is my voice doing this right now
see I tried helping you a shitty bit I
what I said what's that a dick let's
just move it to the side yeah you're
good yeah you're good get some current
events Jim yeah how great was Fanny
Mercury's oh god no mustache yes he did
badly - it sucked
oh now you know this one right this this
is a guy with Tom let's let his we what
is it the Dolphins assistant coach Chris
Forester resigned after a video of him
showing that he was like snorting coke
alright some white substance but this is
before the game is that the video there
I'm submitting it I love it I watch
first taken once I saw that but I
display the video for minha mãe dolphins
are investigating a video which just
surface why is he filming this which he
sent into a girl a stripper thank you
sir starting a powdery substance the
Miami Herald reports a team spokesman
said we were just made aware of the
video and will have no comment at this
time the resistor can be seen in the
video talking straight into the camera
as he does three lines of the white
stuff about how about me going to a
meeting and doing this before I go
that's an old guy truck he wanna Nisha a
model based out of Las Vegas the video
was posted on her Facebook on Facebook
she says I really don't do this often
but
since it's NFL Sunday let's talk about
these coach for according to the Miami
Herald a source familiar with the layout
of offices within the Dolphins facility
says the video seems to take place at a
dolphins office
she's worked 24 seasons in the NFL for
eight different team 24 co-taught 24
seasons in the NFL so I need I need a
little color because I don't know as
much let's let's dilate for a second
number one she's a nasty piece of work
but she probably should know better
because he's that stripper from Vegas
doesn't love you bro so that's also send
our video of you doing but it's okay
you're not gonna get caught it's the
cocaine I don't think he's looking at
khat I think he's an older gentleman
he's listen he spent 2014 NFL so he's
what 60 probably let's say 60 he just
doesn't realize the read he doesn't know
what he's doing so he's just like god
this is what kids do and then also hey
babe can you imagine I'm doing this
before work that's him being dangerous
and hurt like trying to turn her on he
didn't know he didn't stink Tomic she
didn't fathom that someone would blast
this out and [ __ ] him over yeah what's
an assistant coach like explained that
to me like that's a hard job the call
fence line coach
[ __ ] yeah and then I fell yeah took you
very very for you're a difficult job
lots of luck everyone wants that job
yeah hell yeah but he's out the other
side thing decent six figures okay but
also well it's Wesley 24 season NFL he's
spreading him paid pretty well or he
knows he [ __ ] everyone who knows him but
you hear people speak about him like
what the [ __ ] well I've known this guy
forever there's I can't see him doing
this at all so midlife crisis yeah
dealing with a hooker dealing with a
professional let's be real yeah
profession professional that's so nasty
of her to do that I don't know I wonder
what her intention was with posting that
she's just attention
I guess attention yeah yeah sure um but
of course sir
you should know you should know it's
such a shame you doing here yeah I'm not
much younger and I would never send a
picture a video of me doing the NFL yeah
he doesn't realize they have no idea
they're so lost but he's just so you
know why would why would she do it makes
her look stupid
like you just does yeah yeah but also
you've 60 babe look at me and doing it
before I go on and off you go
I mean they just just take me as an
example I could probably get away with
it but then again I do the Goldbergs
where I play a coach for kids on ABC
like I can see ABC going you know no or
we gotta give it you just have to be
aware of that stuff man like I don't
know it's a little different because the
videotape he's a coaching's do it so I
don't think you I'll probably weather it
you know but you couldn't weather if
you're doing on set this is the
difference yeah he did this at the in
his office then for the Miami Dolphins
the plot no you're gonna get fired
well if you do it anyway yeah with no do
they fire him do I put him in drug rehab
and then they bring him back no he know
yet to resign
which is weird they didn't fire him on
the spot because that goes with a whole
nother issue but well they die think in
any organization there's if you're doing
drugs you get a chance to go get help so
a lot of times you have to resign go get
help go get drug counseling and then
we'll have you back
you know I'm sober now I'm back okay you
made a mistake and it feels a little
different I don't think a lot of big
businesses don't it's what you're a
high-level job yeah and if they're not
gonna put up with that so I thought well
I don't think a lot of business is gonna
put up with that if you're doing it in
the offing do they put up with it like
the business is it quietly corporations
and stuff I guess when is that public
it's a little bit more difficult on if
it's not like this and you're in your
you know I don't think so be rush
limbaugh for example had a major oxy
cotton problem or whatever it is and he
had to go and get help and you know get
caught doing in the studio I don't know
probably not on the ground it's you talk
about different yeah yeah it was didn't
your private life and you got a party
not anything he's done using the air
phone never happen back cuz that's a
valuable guy um I'd I bet you I bet he
gets another job for sure I don't think
so he goes get help and then gets
another job with a routine maybe it's a
bummer first family yeah that's the
biggest that he probably was like [ __ ]
yeah I mean that's right what did she
so embarrass a look on the Facebook no
Facebook old man goddamnit what she has
a book with her face on it
no that video of you [ __ ] shorty
crack in the Miami Dolphins office she
released on a huge plot I really
everyone that's any form of
self-sabotage it's just a form I don't
think so I don't think that's fair to
say
I think he's 60 and he didn't realize
what was going on
South sabotage for what because you you
videotape people do weird things it's
not self sabotage B that's a six year
old not knowing what social media come
on
he videotaped it and sent it he doesn't
even have a Facebook account or Twitter
he's 60 he's been in the league for 24
years he has how many children and a
wife there's no self sabotage why would
you want to lose halfway through the
season I don't think so I've had some
videos I've never liked I hope I get
caught here you've discretion he just
doesn't realize no ego now a few is 24
25 or 30 even 35 and he was he's on
social media a lot he's also really high
on coke when you're that high on blow
you're like you know what I'm [ __ ]
sending my girlfriend a video cuz I'm
cool as [ __ ] you're cool [ __ ] I love you
you love me this is a celebration at bay
I'm [ __ ] crazy
many sobered up and went what the [ __ ]
did I do that's actually you got to take
no account the fact that cocaine makes
it he's high cocaine and make you start
with business so he also has he also has
the issues obviously if he's doing it at
this place of work and this is the first
time he's done it's not and that's why
he had to resign yeah what else you got
chin Nellie was arrested for rape what
yeah but but wasn't charged but he was
arrested some some girl called the
police saying that she was sexually
assaulted by him on his tour bus yeah
around like 3 o'clock in the morning so
he actually got arrested they they have
to arrest someone if those claims come
about right I'm assuming after yeah and
so but is there any other facts we can't
hang him out to dry
he's uh no he's he says he's absolutely
innocent and there
to go through the procedures of you know
fighting it he wasn't charged though so
he was just arrested yeah because
there's no evidence it doesn't seem like
3:00 in the morning on the bus yeah
Natalie probably you know although you
never know with guys Joe you know I
never know that NFL player Jamie sharp
or the [ __ ] his name is Darren Sharper
yeah who raped that was you know roofing
girls these he makes Nellie look like it
turd with eyes there's also there's also
this thing where you know if you if you
accuse somebody of rape and there are no
charges you can sue them simple case to
sue them for defamation of character
yeah but you can sue them for rape - if
there's no evidence and you get yeah
there's a whole lot of speculation a 3
a.m. tour bus who knows what happened in
there obscene l he's a big name I'm not
saying he didn't do it I'm saying I'm
waiting to see what else comes about did
you see him though over the weekend he
had like a 7 year old girl come up on
stage and he was like playing with her
hair and this is all within like I think
the same weekend or think your clothes
did you there's a video but what is it
like he was helping the 7 girl down like
it was just weird like like he was like
singing to her and I think he was just
trying to be like oh like you know like
it was it was kind of creepy he was like
like nose to nose with her I don't if
you can find it Nellie 7 year old girl
but he got a lot of backlash from this
that were people are upset about mm-hmm
somebody accuses you something like that
I saw on Instagram mmm it's a little
weird and he's playing with her hair as
he's singing to her nose to nose like
this
[Music]
he's kissing her head no but there's
another video where he's literally like
I'm not saying you know I didn't I don't
know the full story but I think backlash
that's all this isn't the one that's a
13 it's gonna be this long keep me away
from the 8 year old yeah that the girl
no right that's the one nice people look
but he's getting backlash from our
[ __ ] idiot yeah because this 8 year
olds a huge fan so he made her [ __ ]
yeah year by bringing onstage I was
little yeah yeah I'm a fan of him I like
his music so yeah [ __ ] up thing about
getting accused I mean there are always
gonna people mm-hmm wait till the
evidence comes out what if she got to
that okay today is Columbus Day right uh
you mean and Dinges indigenous people
day depending where you're from yeah so
a bunch of cities are not take they're
changing it to indigenous peoples day
man yeah of course
sorry please eat that into the mic so
everyone stops listening um yeah how
about that but you know I think certain
areas have decided not to call Columbus
Day LA
Isabella throws Burbank really we don't
call Columbus Day anymore no Austin
Berkeley Burbank Berkeley did it 25
years ago
goddamn Berkeley taking the game
Berkeley's always on them um yeah
Columbus Day now kids you I can't
remember if we get Columbus Day Off or
not the school across the street from me
did not have it off is people's day -
there's it always cracks me up that
indigenous people are somehow more noble
than the the Spanish French English you
know whatever the Western people that
came in and conquered it always crossed
me up because it's all it's all
horseshit because the indigenous people
when were the indigenous and the idea
that indigenous people if you listen to
Native American Historians guys like
Steve Rinella the amount of fighting
among for example Native Americans and
the amount of fighting that went on
between the Maori and the Samoan and the
amount of fighting that always went on
with the Aztec I mean with the the Aztec
empire wasn't exactly peace-loving maybe
I don't you think anyone saying that no
Americans work yeah I mean it's true
that you know um this apparently I read
when I was a history in high school what
I heard was Columbus gave the Native
Americans pox-ridden blankets
there was a great I don't think anyone's
saying that famous brother well I'm just
saying although they were absolutely
history is one in which there was always
empire and there was always there was
always one stronger group that would
come in and subjugate another group and
we can go all the way back to history
the Assyrians the Babylonians the
Persians if it just goes on and on the
Romans weeks but be so a little for me
to the correlating he said to correlate
with this cuz you little all over the
place so collate with this you're saying
that it what this is is that this is a a
sort of salute to the indigenous people
that were conquered by Columbus that you
know so the idea was that the people
that were here who were indigenous to
this region were essentially subjugated
by you know the way Cortes did and the
way various like people did to the
Aztecs to the Incas and I understand
there's a sensitivity there but it's it
tends to be a little bit one-sided
sometimes to me I don't care about
connect Columbus Day it's not I
understand America you know in other
words the Europeans discovered American
when I say we Christmas but we
discovered America hired Christopher
Columbus like accidentally found America
he's always looking for a trade route
yeah and just like what the [ __ ] is this
is that how the ideon terminology came
around because he thought he was in
India
instead of a better trade routes I think
for the spice trade and things like that
yeah that's why you can't refer to me as
Indians Christopher Columbus was from
where and also don't call them savages
this is Spain mmm that out please do you
not know I do
we're we're would let's do before you
look it up we're LA dollars up Chris
Bahamas was Italian okay oh yeah that's
that's right but looking look it up for
sure does not sound like an Italian name
no it does it I thought it was Spanish
please from Spain come on this is an
Italian explorer navigator and
colonizers but a lot of people a lot of
people think that he was from Spain why
click on that huh he was from Genoa and
well what the people do what the
indigenous day people want is for
today's to studying Native Americans and
not the study of Christopher Columbus
yes maybe I don't know steady bowl I was
about about that study both that's
exactly right we we learned a lot about
Native Americans uh-huh Geronimo well
the great thing is that there is this
great this this idea that the Native
Americans lived in harmony with their
environment true more more so than did
the Westerners that came in shot all the
Buffalo and [ __ ] laid railroad tracks
and stuff like that however there is a
lot of evidence to suggest that
indigenous people because they were
human beings just like everybody came in
and killed so many of the megafauna that
were indigenous at the time to say the
continental United States to South
America dude it's it's always human
beings we as an ape have come in war and
by radically changed our environment I
mean that's pretty well known but I
don't think you're breaking any I'm just
saying I'm just saying that that that
that you know there were peaceful people
know and they were and human beings
educate people whether Indian whatever
we're not so in harmony with their
environment they hunted the [ __ ] out of
everything it was around because I had
to and got very good at it we're very at
where X
not the giant sloths and all those
things you see at the La Brea Tar Pits
that disappeared people attribute to
climate change a lot of scientists would
suggest no in fact they were probably
hunted to extinction because they
reproduce very slowly you ever seen a
giant sloth again in person but this
book picture about nice long yes not
easy that would be the [ __ ] I feel giant
you and I could hit right now spin I
know I love a sloth
I would love a piss out there like 20
feet 20 feet high Yubel Harare and there
is a ground work on that well you know
Harare in his book sapiens everybody
please read that yeah I think terrifying
although we could kill holy mammoths
then apparently apparently you can bring
those back dressed part style do you
know this yes yes there's the working of
the woolly man DNA yes
straight up dress part by the way look
at that beautiful slaw with the manikins
fingers in the world yep the mammoth was
eaten like a [ __ ] look at the
size of the 20 feet high
look at that look at that man next to it
that's a lot of meat dude how cool would
that be
Devas a pet yeah the people that came
into Siberia and went to Alaska they
were following the wooly mammoths they
thought and they've thrived and they ate
the [ __ ] head of the wooly mammoth
William has have a gestation period of a
long time I think it's two years or but
back then they had no idea to them it's
me no I really didn't know you're gonna
fight you'll you know people are gonna
come in and right with him to correct
that's a giant germ all those megafauna
that that were dead that disappeared all
these animals that were extinct by the
time you know probably what that
saber-toothed tiger went extinct thirty
thousand years ago I think it is that's
a piece of [ __ ] from that Johnny sloth
honestly I thought the turds would be
bigger not that impressed claw let's say
they're giant you hold one so well they
like they look like those shitty
Brazilian nuts yeah yeah hey look up
that wolf there's a bear that's like a
cat that that they think killed a lot of
people Bearcat it's a [ __ ] giant bear
I can't marry that - it looks like a
lion bear it's like a [ __ ] you talk
about a lighter no oh that's a red panda
he was here when when we came over the
Bering Strait I guess on chin Google
giant Bearcat lion here
oh wait no that's not that's just a lion
chasing them dude these things have
shorts my bro
is it a liners that a beer no it's a
it's a bear it had it could run much
faster it was huge look at the size it's
gotta be this one then oversized lions -
that's to be though back in the day now
there are oversized lions dude how
gnarly were [ __ ] it were and there it is
there and I see that bear right there
with the short snout to the left right
there right [ __ ] there yeah the
short-faced bear wreaked havoc that's a
lion thing looks like [ __ ] oh it's a
giant it was a giant yes go back chin
coz there was a look is where wha where
were you just out oh click I'm not maybe
that's why it's so scary looking there
it's like a rhino
damn that fur that things that's a
furrier I know moisture in the furrier I
know they're bad they're huge lions I'm
saber-toothed Tigers dude how how
[ __ ] how crazy was a backup restore
different animals raising those giant
negly one or what I was like the the
creatures in the sea yeah feel like
there was so much cooler than human Homo
sapiens came over into I guess they
crossed over the Bering Strait they
crossed it through Alaska well we're
taught hold on while we're talking about
animals and this I was talking about
megalodons and other crazy animals I'm
just gonna warn everybody right now I
watched that movie 47 meters
oh my many more my wife watched that -
did you like it
she thought it was scary [ __ ] makes you
uncomfortable wait a minute oh my holes
wait for it wait for it never seen hey
hold on hey hon good review review worst
movie I've seen hold on careful now
don't exaggerate well how was the movie
good
I would rather you take a saber-toothed
tiger tooth and Ram it up my people than
watch that again it's not that bad 47
meters down mm-hmm what the director of
Jaws lake hey has a horse movie
I'll watch it as far as it went to
theaters is more like it was a theater
for three hours I saw a way to get it
out of here
I'm not skill that friendly sure you
ever see what someone changes the teeth
on the great white no normal teeth and
they look friendly as [ __ ] have you ever
seen that I do that Jago a great white
with human teeth it's like a great white
shark you input put on those things no I
know I know they're horrible so look at
[Applause]
that one that's the Laughing shark they
call that the Laughing shark yeah any
city okay use characters will change
their teeth they like holy [ __ ] I want
one yep where's Jim I would swim all
over the sea if that thing is out there
so what I I'm afraid that maybe not that
one not that one that one looks like the
French gaze how long does the Iceland
shark live guys hmm five hundred two
hundred five ceiling up cool the cat Dan
was by death teeth they crazy no I gotta
change my training hey what else you got
you uh let's do this one huh Harvey
Weinstein every a lot of actresses are
coming out and blasting him saying he
did sexually he's so screwed dude he got
fired from The Weinstein whatever I've
been in this business for 22 23 years
here in LA I've been hearing stories
about that guy from sources reliable
enough like girlfriends I dated and was
dating at the time but it's kind of
known around Hollywood yes like no one's
surprise here in that store everyone I
know that exact scenario of him come out
coming out and make so what Meryl Streep
called looks like everyone said
disgraceful excuse all right
but uh much people call it Kathie Lee
Griffin said that he masturbated in
front of her
I think the kind of icing on the cake or
that the needle that broke the camel's
back was he got caught or not got caught
so we're talking about he jacked off
into a plant yeah man I i I've heard
plenty of stories of him coming running
out and just naked there's a I guess
there's a lot more they're gonna come up
with a sign non-disclosures but he's
super screwed for decades well he looks
creepy he does he really does
he's oh my god he looks like the bad
character you'd cast in the movie for
jacking off in plans so my friend my
friend worked with him and he was like
yeah really close we're working you know
you know the guy I'll tell you about it
later but I might feel historians like
yeah we're working together I'm like his
son at this point is great and then he
and my other buddy who worked with him
for a while they go home I go what's
going on with the Winston Harvey is he
just he lies
he's just so trouble this lie like so
blame me but then he's okay about it's
just the business which is again that
I'm like alright alright you know don't
be lying here he's very good at his job
the guy could find ya those movies about
he knows how I go why so good ego schizo
talent he and his brother I why I said
why has he been around for so long
okay so tell ya here's a feeling way at
work but he is I mean I could be maybe
more gross ah
you imagine being a young woman try
making high when he comes out jacking
off in his towel when you do good and
he's God so you as a woman you're like
what am I gonna do this guy's
sitting in a bathtub now what I suck
everyone seems dick to be the next
battement oh my imagine kids in that
yeah he's not a troll looks like the guy
eats trolls from the movie trolls yeah
he's one of the fun talk about being
exposed when all those women come out
and they're like yeah he would here's
all his pants so his Heat start coming
on so is he gonna get prison time how's
that work I think that he just gets
disgraced and he does the Cosby thing
just kind of goes embarrassing and now
he
to take a backseat which is awful for
him oh he can't he can't be the man he
was the man like you're the man when you
walk into a into a room at Sundance or
whatever and everybody's kissing your
ass cuz everybody wants to be a business
and now now it's embarrassing man look
at jay-z mm-hmm he knows he's crazy
jay-z's like what the [ __ ] they're doing
not anymore what else yeah a bad guy
yeah oh do you guys know about Jeremy
Lin
getting dreadlocks it's like a yeah you
got dreadlocks and people were hitting
with a hate loan yeah people were hate
not I like him now he's not Keys Chinese
Chinese yeah I like his hair I think I
think he did that so you can start the
conversation if people you know people
getting to know other cultures but a lot
of people don't like it like a lot of
not a lot but some black players don't
like it why only only black goons never
Prius right
so [ __ ] out here is appropriation
cultural appropriation is how we advance
all of the best parts of people's
cultures you [ __ ] dummy man so so
Kenyon Martin who's a famous
african-american player in the NBA used
to retired now has a problem with his
drug he did have from what he say he
didn't please plays like that do I need
to remind this damn boy to his last name
lean this man right there is no way
possible man he would have made on one I
t's man with that [ __ ] going on
man I come on man like somebody really
need to tell him I I
I brought we get it you get it like you
want to be black like we get it but the
last name is name well that's kind of
not to mention he has a bunch of Asian
tattoos yeah like it symbols in sign
isn't but everybody should take see if
you pick up a history book all of our
everybody who has brahmana's we are all
products of a mixture of cultures and by
the way we're all products of Empire
we're all products of of another country
coming in and taking over that country
in did the original cultures that that
were in the thousands no longer exist
they were all brought together by the
Romans by the Greeks again we're all a
product of all so many different
cultures and so is he so is Kenyon
Martin from the language he speaks to
the food he eats they're looking hard to
drive everything every day it is a
mixture of cultures and what makes
things great is ideas sex is a mixture
I'm sorry to bring this up but this is
what we talk about are mixed mental arts
this is the [ __ ] point is you want to
mix you want to have ideas sex you want
it you want to be you wanna have
cultural sex this country is great
because of a cultural appropriation when
you eat a burrito it's got rice from
China meat from the old world
it's got [ __ ] peppers and tomatoes
from the new world it's all a mixture
man it's got Aztec it's got Spanish it's
got Asian it's got [ __ ] you know and
it's got American that's what a burrito
is do you like burritos if you don't
then you might want to leave my country
and that's an example idea sex so Jeremy
Lin can't have dreads because his last
name is Lin
oh so you're if you're Chinese if you
come from that part of the world you're
not allowed to dread your hair mmm
interesting so now there's a way you
have to wear your hair you have to just
extrapolate this [ __ ] but Kenyon
Mart is not a deep thinker he's a
[ __ ] uh you know he's just reacting
in his own way he's having a moment and
probably being half he's only being half
serious problem so [ __ ] it you got a lot
of hate backs oh yeah oh yeah yeah
backed up a little
yeah it's called freedom of expression
and I celebrate it and I like treads on
Jeremy Lin and I like treads on white
people well I don't like [ __ ] you know
what I'm doing say that for white people
don't live dreads hey pull up hot white
people with dreads sometimes a blonde is
dreads like a surfer great there's a few
girls that like half dreads whoa yeah
I've always liked dreads honestly I
really have dreads are cool I think
that's cool I think those guys look cool
the girl
they're super smelly the blonde I come
dude
she looks pretty down below oh that one
she's pretty yeah yeah those are like
sorta yeah those were half dressed I'll
choice and nobody owns a style choice
no one we can all do in Berg oh gosh
that's a wig yeah be hilarious if we
actually had them it's all good man
that's two people everywhere
white people with dreads gonna freak me
out or whatever I don't give a flying
[ __ ] I do it mmm hey sweetie I wanted
red my hair I want to who's the first to
do dreads jamaicans that's usually where
I keep my Bob Marley made it huge
remember I think I was going on way back
right to put wax because you gotta put
wax in your hair to do it not wash yeah
that's how you okay Christian Aguilar
got a bunch of slack for her braids
which I know I think it's goes cool at
the time this was like early to child
you know you la might be Spanish is that
what she's been I guess if you're
Mexican or if you're Latin you can't
have that either
okay yes some people yeah the way the
way not to advance things is with
identity politics that's the enemy
that's the biggest bunch of [ __ ] in
the world because I you know it's like I
think most people make this world
don't give a [ __ ] so I write like white
Kenyon Martin talking about that it
doesn't do your water right well do it
but it doesn't matter why do we care
what what do you think why would you
care yeah the high the the influencers
aren't gonna really that's a good point
comment on that I agree a hundred
percent when I sketch in dread smell
like [ __ ] though they do
MJ you want to talk about this one oh
sure
have you guys heard about this um the
crazies over the Szechuan sauce yeah so
okay there's this TV show called Rick
and Morty it's on after Family Guy on
Cartoon Network super crass though like
it's way worse than South Park and many
buzzes wait way more on edge I guess you
could say they push a lot of boundaries
but it's it's hilarious it's really
funny um they just finished their third
season so Rick who's the mad scientist
and it he ohi's is like bitching that he
wants a Szechuan sauce Szechuan sauce
came out in 1998 with the LA I see Josh
Lewis okay so it's like the special
sauce they brought it out ninety eight
from Milan and they didn't bring it back
out and people have always wanted
McDonald to bring it back and now it's
getting notoriety with the show
McDonald's brought it back for one day
this weekend and then everyone the
show's be huge it's you drink more tea
on my phone like a sticker of Rick and
Morty like people like got pissed off
because they ran out all the McDonald's
right now people who are lining up
there's a boycott one to boycott
McDonald's and because they ran out of a
session oh because the Szechuan sauce
they ran out of Szechuan sauce and
people are like oh what you only had 20
packets a special honor sauce inside
your restaurant and like all this random
[ __ ] but now I guess McDonald spoke
back and they're gonna bring hold up
McDonald's just they tweet out you spoke
we've listened lots of Secession sauce
and location detail soon and that's
fourteen thousand retweets twenty nine
thousand like Rick and Morty's a huge
show it's a really really pop it's
really it's funny for them to force
McDonald's to change the policy they
must be their fans must be rabbits there
I think it's done to like [ __ ] on
Twitter and social media about these
goddamn
not yet now if you live that's my key no
that's when you know you take your food
seriously I think it's good though cuz
it shows you the kind of like loyal
following a show like what's it called
Ricki burger party the show it also
shows these corporations the type of
power certain shows can have they have
hats that say Szechuan sauce now and you
can find them on the internet for like
20 bucks 30 bucks even like 80 bucks on
like those bougie boutiques it's crazy
but just goes to show you like these
little like subcultures can definitely
affect things sure which is awesome yeah
I have I've never I'm gonna watch the
show now by the way what is typically
typically a very hot typically Szechuan
sauce is spicy sriracha yeah it's like
it's kind of a viscous like with with
our red see what it looks like China
flags in it [ __ ] with it Jim
I want our two Chinese restaurants all
Chinese restaurants have it I don't know
all of them but anyone has any send is
it that's Szechuan is this type of
cooking yeah and it's got peppers in it
here see what's in Szechuan sauce oh
gosh
oh let me guess I'm gonna say soy sauce
red peppers chili pepper mushroom sauce
okay
soy beans salt alcohol no let me go back
hot and spicy there we go
well that's Tamra sauce right apple
cider vinegar yeah but is that it it's a
Camry soy sauce dude let's see let's see
what Szechuan sauce says well he's on
Szechuan I think that I didn't know yes
but no soy sauce recipe genius kitchen
well that's a that's a homemade recipe
mix ginger garlic red pepper soy chili
garlic sauce and sugar in a pan and
warms him near boiling combined brown
and corn straw and cornstarch and small
burro bowl stir to dissolve all right
well you just taste red peppers and
garlic so it's Chinese yeah well sorry
it's delicious everyone relax
ginger get some ginger that's dry sherry
I'll try it
garlic try crushed red pepper I'll tell
you why it makes that with a little
chicken
sandwich what's that signature for it's
really good and one right up the street
really by the freeway their milk sure
you know where bread peppers are
indigenous to where they come from
could you please tell us cuz we don't
even know South America the South
America what else he got chin-checked
this guy I don't know how this is even
possible
uh he's this guy and has arrested first
twenty eight DUI Wow w3 what's that
weapon two three strikes rule no this is
this is Minnesota I tried to get drunk
he looks like he's done everything wrong
in him never made a right decision has a
ham newton been shamed into apologize
apologize right run off I didn't get
that either why is that such a if you
watch it it's like you know I'm a big
Cam Newton family watch like uh what are
you what he said being a leader of an
organization like you gotta know better
this female reporter who's been
reporting on their felt for quite some
time she's actually reporting for the
Carolina Panthers asked about route
running and he goes it's hilarious to
hear a woman asked about route running
well he'd never heard it probably so
that was an honest kind of I never heard
a woman asked about routes cuz that is a
very like I'm a woman said that I'd be
like you asked me just to you know she's
the NFL reporter yeah that's an
interesting outfit he always dresses
crazy yeah this thing yeah when you see
it you're like oh why would you do that
man
but then she no don't defend him
everybody listen listen I'm gonna happy
out there so he does that she comes to
him after and he's a dick to her
afterwards like she was like whoa I've
been working for Carolina Panthers come
and football she needs to take him
seriously yeah super dick about it
okay so then Dan and dropped them his
sponsor dropped them and then he came
out do things that guy have daughters if
I should have said that and but the
funny thing is
is is I don't think anyone she lost
sponsor their jobs over I no one did but
so he lost the sponsor but then the girl
talking all that [ __ ] she was like this
is how it is in my line of business wall
of water well they go back and they find
that she tweeted on 212 like driving my
dad through the south he's making the
best racist jokes ever hashtag racist
jokes are so funny so it's like well see
what he did wrong by the way maybe his
dad maybe her dad was not a bad guy
maybe that maybe that is telling funny
racist jokes she's laughing cuz they're
outrageous and neither one of them
believe it like let's all take a step
back and it's it's the public
marketplace is very unforgiving so we'll
be live in them yeah well like I tweet
then so I've nothing's innocent so I
blast out this dove ad campaign cuz
people tagged me at when I look at this
shot and it's that and then people like
no you just see the whole ad man like
it's [ __ ] up like the whole ad goes
through shows all these different races
people just want it to paint the
pictures that they want you know like
black to white yes either way I didn't
post it cuz I give a flying [ __ ] I buzz
because the worst mark in the world it's
hilarious how that got past the big
corporation like duh yeah even when you
look at it going through the different
ethnic you know through Asian white
black even that's a bad idea
so that doesn't give him a free pass and
they've got in trouble before for
posting stupid [ __ ] like this I I think
we're all I don't post it to make you
know you suck you conscious of Dov being
racist I don't think the race is I just
think they're more I don't think most
Americans identify as racist who I do I
don't I do I don't think so at all I do
I mean if that's the case explain why
Barack Obama won won two elections in a
row a black man as our president I mean
you it's it's you got to give people at
least some credit we've come a long
[ __ ] way by the way what I think it's
really funny is even neo-nazis racism is
such a 4-letter world that even
neo-nazis so funny they're like I'm not
a racist
I'm not I'm just pro white and they go I
mean Jews are different they're not
people I mean here it's unbelievably
race even obviously but even the extreme
will defend themselves again
the notion that there are racists now
that's a bad example but the last
example no it's not because I don't
think most Americans I think it's unfair
to say that most Americans are racist or
identify that way I don't know well I
don't say the majority of racists I
think there's a lot of racism in America
I think we can all flan way though they
coming along way I would come a long way
even credit that's a long way we've come
a long way we still have a long ways to
you know if you say anything racist
nowadays there's such ramifications so
so talk about protections talk about the
idea that you have a voice at least I
think that there are there is a legacy
of racism that has that we are dealing
with like the residue of poor schooling
and neighborhoods that were redlined so
you have like ghettos and things like
that yes I think we're dealing with that
but I think I think there are a lot of
Americans who believe in fair play and a
meritocracy and I frankly think most
Americans like the great thing is a
[ __ ] out what's-his-name Steve man
and on Charlie Rose really interesting
or an interview it's like Hillary
Clinton because they were talking about
transgender bathrooms running 82
articles in a period of like two months
in the New York Times about transgender
bathrooms and he said 50% of Americans
have 400 dollars in the bank
$400 think about that for a second when
you have 400 dollars in the bank and you
lost your job because of illegal
immigration or globalism because those
jobs went overseas you can talk all you
want at the end of the day you don't
have money and a way to earn a living
and you can't even provide for your kids
you're not thinking you're not thinking
about you don't even think about race
you're just thinking about where can I
make more money
yeah and and we have to you have to
recognize that which is one of the
biggest reasons Trump won so you know
politicians the media Hollywood Wall
Street all those people all of us are
out of touch because everybody lives in
a bubble you know it's a really maybe
that's my dropping knowledge by the way
but I want to do your draw I want to do
that thing you sent me interesting right
yeah you said Jamel Hill Jamil Hill got
suspended by ESPN though remember the
one that came out about Trump tweeted
out about Trump talking [ __ ] in Trump
saying he's a racist oh you guys haven't
seen this know what to her okay oh yeah
I saw that yeah she's on the 6:00 with
SportsCenter show so I thought she was
pretty
she did it again though she did it again
so what what does she had spent for this
time I guess the journalist is supposed
to be somewhat if she wanted Vance to
boycott that FL sorry
so he called L Hilda comes for the
senator who called for Finn's boy cut
that off after label and President Trump
a whites press on Twitter has been
suspended for two weeks
scroll down change happens when aft eyes
were impacted if you strongly reject
what Jerry Jones said the key is the
advertisers and then she gets suspended
Donald Trump's a white supremacist who
has largely surrounded himself with yeah
I love this because this is what makes
America great everybody has a point of
view let's have a debate about it
speak your mind you do work for a
corporation
I guess there's ways to do things it's
if you know what the problem is when you
have a brand like ESPN or CNN and you
have a journalist that goes off like
that you lose your your impartiality and
it can hurt your brand's yeah but
they're also a corporation that are out
through through Disney and they're also
they benefit from the NFL braiding so
when she goes boycott the NFL their
biggest moneymaker they're gonna go when
we can't have yeah and I and that's fair
you there's a time and a place to
express your opinion there's a time in a
place if people are studying in a
library and you come in and you start to
express your opinion well that's a weird
ways where can she express her opinions
I I think this is her social I think you
can express that's a very as you were
just saying he questioned it's a sticky
question cuz if you're an employee and
you didn't do it on chin doing her
showing his pin she doesn't she's
something on ESPN initially I remember
no no she already know this all comes
from her social media it comes she
hasn't chin said any of this on her
should I I think that they would
probably say you know is it is it
connected to
ESPN did you do it from work I mean
there's all kinds of issues but it's a
very weak form it's a question but we're
it's a good question because where do
you draw the line are you allowed as a
when you're not working are you allowed
to speak your mind there is the First
Amendment but again to your point if you
are working for an organization that is
directly tied to the a to the NFL and
you tell people they should boycott it I
think that company has the right to
suspend you that company has a right to
say you are you are known present you
don't agree with what you're doing you
can for what we represent we're gonna
suspend you right two weeks because it's
a conflict of interest right if you if I
produce a product and I have an employee
goes this products [ __ ] don't buy it
I can't have you working for my company
because you don't believe in it's it's
it's it's it you have to kind of
extrapolate that's that simplicity I
just started with you know I'm saying
she talks about ESPN uh no but when you
say boycott the NFB the NFL what did she
actually get suspended for same boycott
the NFL yeah okay and her company the
ESPN is what how does it benefit from
the NFL during Monday Night Football on
ESPN they paid 14 billion yeah well how
much did they pay for so there they're
there in extra some crazy [ __ ]
financially inextricably linked right so
3.2 billion
there you go and do that 11 - eros
Monday Night Football okay so then I
felt in its content are obviously
extremely valuable to ESPN and Hill's
latest violation will cost her two weeks
of her work
yes been declined comment regarding
whether or not he'll will be paid during
the suspension then FL decline to
comment she'll go speak at colleges and
make a fortune um not really
you don't wanna lose that gig no but
don't you so what do you pipe down I
don't where can she voice how she feels
if she's if she hates time in a place
time in a place we got BB keep saying
because if you're working for a
corporation but your social name yes and
you tweet that you're exactly like
somebody gets fired because they tweet
something
that is not that is not indicative of
the culture of that corporation okay so
if I am working city but if I'm not
anymore not anymore if I'm working for
Google or whoever it might be and I say
my favorite my brothers accounts
probably I think that's right for a long
time because he's worked on to do it she
was getting you'd post something people
like all big dick bandit like because
there's something called a corporate
culture and corporate portal protocol
and you can't have big dick bandits big
dick banner is works like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is gonna have a bat dick
there's always this cognitive dissonance
this is this is huge like you're always
gonna have to way sort of do different
value originally this started with this
donald trump is a white supremacy has
surround himself with other white
supremacists
she called him the most ignorant
offensive president of my lifetime
he'll also call trump a bigoted and
unqualified and unfit to be President
she even added if you were not white he
would never been elected so this is a
great this is actually a great dropping
knowledge to work into because this is
something called cognitive dissonance
and we all deal with this and what that
means is there's a conflict of interest
there there's there's conflicting values
that we all have so for example we
believe in equality right but so all men
are created equal so if you believe in
equality that's that's one idea but if
you also believe in a meritocracy if you
also believe in in democracy capitalism
if you believe in a marketplace in a way
you can't really keep people equal
unless you keep people who are really
good at producing down we're always
working with that slavery was what made
our country a modern country the the
massive contradiction in the fact that
the founding fathers in this country was
founded and predicated on the concept
that all men are created equal and have
certain unalienable rights under our
Creator which are life liberty and
because
but by the way these black people well
not really because you know this thing
called white gold which is cotton we got
all this free labor and an entire
economy is built on it that forcing
people to have to contend with that that
sort of like major disparity is how
cultures actually evolve because it
stirs debate it stirs conflict it stirs
people to kind of call each other out on
how are you living you believe in this
mean look at immigration immigration
illegal immigration is a classic example
there are people who are refugees who
are coming over look at the dreamers I
don't want to kick those people out but
then there is also the idea that okay we
believe in mercy we believe people give
it and that some people just need help
but then you also have to weigh
something called justice which is people
that are already here
and a limited amount of resources and
the fact that Alima illegal immigrants
are taking jobs away from mexicans and
other people that actually came here
legally so so it's a very difficult
conversation a very difficult thing to
you're weighing to values and when you
have to wait two values that cognitive
distance is actually how a culture grows
and a culture evolves because you have
spirited debate and you come within to a
compromise that's how laws are made do
that do that drop in knowledge because I
read this do you stop that article I say
yeah I want to do that too that that's
that is this the last one
I read this drop a knowledge because
again when whenever we talk about guns
we get so much I get I get so many
articles and people with their ideas and
how they feel about it and then this one
I found on my own from Washington Post
yeah I got and this was written by
goddesses this yeah this was written by
a woman who's anti-gun yeah she's her
name is Leah libretto and she was she's
a statistician and former news writer at
thirty five eight which is a data
journalism site and she's the author of
arriving at Amen and she's I thought it
was very interesting because she is
somebody who is essentially you know
pro-gun control and anti gun but she
found that so so what happens is when
there's a terrible event like Las Vegas
we all start talking about gunk
control and politicians have to do
something too so they start common
jumping up there with sort of different
reforms let's get rid of bump stocks
okay let's get rid of different things
and then she kind of realized that so
many of she spent three months analyzing
all 33,000 lives ended by guns each year
in the United States and she said she
found it roundup completely frustrated
with what would really work because it's
a case-by-case basis for so for example
when you talk about getting rid of guns
like automatic weapons okay or assault
rifles okay for example or gun laws like
making sure you know - cutting down on
gun laws she went into it going we've
got to fix the gun laws we gotta fix
something this isn't right yeah she goes
she goes mass shootings were to where
they're always bring up Australia they
had a very very successful Romans she
goes mass shootings were way too wet
rare in Australia for their absence
after the buyback program to be clear
evidence of progress you can't take you
know such as such a rare occurrence and
then extrapolate you know but what I
thought was really interesting in this
is that she talked about like assault
weapons
that's a classification that includes
any semi-automatic weapon that has two
or more features such as bayonet mounts
a rocket-propelled grenade launcher
mount a folding stock or a pistol grip
but you know guns are she was talking
about how guns are so modular a lot of
this stuff can be done in somebody's
workshop okay silencers are another
thing like silencers in the movies
whether like like that that's not really
yeah when you I've shot silenced I've
shot silenced rifles I shot a 50 caliber
SIA with a huge silencer on it I shot
assault weapons with silencers which she
talks about how they it's like research
on them and yeah it's just that it's not
gonna blow your gems out but I mean it
well and everyone this office would hear
yeah an ar-15 with the sound sir it's
about as loud as a jackhammer okay goosh
goosh you know I mean it's loud that's
what the silence yeah the point is to
make to make the did not destroy your
hearing but they kept looking through
all the data and what what I thought was
really interesting is two-thirds and
nobody talks about this two-thirds of
gun deaths in the United States every
year are suicides so when you talk about
you know 33,000 people are killed a year
with guns that hold on hold on
two-thirds of those are suicides so
if either one of you have these crazy
gun laws yes people soon find ways with
its automatic whatever bumper wood
they're gonna find ways to kill
themselves the other thing is that that
most of those guns and most of the
deaths from guns in this country are
handguns they are not assault rifles
about the the next group were young men
ages 15 to 34 killed in homicides and
that's mainly gang-related yes yes
they're more likely to die at the hands
of other young men often related to gang
loyalties and other street violence and
the last notable group of similar deaths
was the 1700 women murder per year
usually as a result of domestic violence
so far more people were killed in these
ways than in mass shooting incidents so
we have to keep these things in the
context okay when you're trying to make
the world safer of course you make sure
there's you could say well if the gun
laws were stricter than that [ __ ] who
did the Vegas shooting wouldn't be able
to do as much damage if he didn't have
those type of guns but then they say
even if you did have these rules and
regulations on those bumps and those
assault rifles they these guys can go
and do it themselves no matter what Lal
you up in place they can do it
themselves a lot of times they buy the
gun not like that go home and created
themselves or for example they always
talk about you know well you got to have
mental health screening okay cool
so Adam Lanza Adam Lanza's mother had
guns and she was totally she went
through all the background checking
everything on Lanza he killed all those
children and Stoneybrook or whatever
it's called San Diego City well Adam
Lanza was a [ __ ] cuckoo bird who took
his mother's guns and killed his mother
so you know you're gonna have you might
have a family member this crazy these
things are very hard to legislate and
one of the things she who is anti-gun
but I thought it's very fair and her
article who says is that you've got to
do this like you've got to kind of do it
a case-by-case or pinpoint so if you
have an abusive husband who's been
beating the [ __ ] out of his wife that
might be a guy you might say you can't
get a gun and you might have to go do
the interview when you have gang members
that are shooting or they might like
they may be likely to kill somebody
you've got to do that case-by-case basis
it's not easy but you got to go in there
and
you're out what you can do for that
young man to get him out of that
situation thing that she says and she
goes when I went into this gun we need
stricter gun laws everything which I've
been you know I my opinion I think we
need stricter gun laws and there's also
a gun issue but when you look in the
facts and these numbers which I was
surprised by she goes I'm even more
discouraged now because I don't have an
answer and she looked all strict gun
laws is there so many gun laws as it is
right now yeah but she's saying like
when everyone goes oh any strict gun
laws this this this that's not the
answer because when you look at the
facts that's not the issue right that's
what she was I'm more discouraged yeah
it did there is no clear answer here you
know one no one has the right answer
people have their right to feel that
this should be stricter gun laws people
who are gun long abiding citizens have
their right to feel like more guns you
know I don't think that animal think
blankets the house there's no one answer
so though let's do this guy's a good guy
with a gun usually you got the SWAT team
in there to kill that guy before you
know and he killed himself but you know
in that in that case there were could
have been everybody could've had a gun
and they didn't know where the shots
were coming from so there's always a way
around that so in that case not so much
my one thing about the Second Amendment
guys and I believe in the Second
Amendment but my one thing about the
Second Amendment guys I think it's a
romantic argument is that they'll say
well we need a standing militia we need
to be able to fight government tyranny
in case the government turns on us and
you know they try to take us over that's
always been a long-standing you know
it's always like us I think John Adams
lost the art applause the election of
1800 because he believes in a standing
army the founding fathers were very very
worried about having a standing army
because they would they were afraid that
a charismatic leader like Napoleon could
take that army over and essentially you
know run a military dictatorship that
was always a fear with Americans and
should be but the idea that a lot of
these Second Amendment guys goes I have
my guns and if the government comes to
me I'll be ready listen bro listen
that's a [ __ ] pipe dream because the
fact of the matter is your government
has a monopoly on violence a federal
government probably should and if you
think your ak-47 your your sniper 50
caliber sniper rifle or even your
machine guns you have class three
license for if you think that's going to
stop
you're out of your [ __ ] mind it ain't
so that's a little bit that's a little
bit of a romantic argument I get it I
have a little bit of myself but it's it
doesn't hold water it's [ __ ] does
interesting man yeah there's no right
answer I I'm it's okay to say that I say
that all the time
I don't know I don't [ __ ] know but I
know a lot of times when when politics
are slower than both of us trying to
figure it out so you don't have an
answer so exactly yeah yeah yeah there
I'm knowledge but I thought it was
interesting though because the minute
you brought it up you realized right
away how a politician can't even talk
about this [ __ ] unless you're on one
team or another I told you I went
whenever talk about guns we get so much
weird feedback it's such a sensitive
topic for everybody Oh chill man chill
I'm not making long just those deep in
the American character so Americans
identify with their cars and their guns
guns and ray guns and race soup I can't
talk about it yes yes that's why we need
to buy guns I got something cute dance I
have somebody I have some yeah you do
too yes they do
yep you got you got you got some guns I
got this gun all night just like I just
feel good having one I feel like a [ __ ]
heaven when I wish I don't have to have
one but what can you do good good talk
Thanks remember uh before the show aired
we accidentally kissed yeah my my tongue
touched your upper lip yeah that
happened we have video of it happens
yeah why do you think that happened get
too close hey hey hey you're cute yeah I
can't kill you wave oh yeah bleep oh
yeah kid we're waiting for you guys uh I
brought let me get your number all right
man weird hey guess what guys speaking
of your comedy number if you guys like
to laugh if you don't like to laugh if
you don't like laughing real hard for an
hour straight or more don't come to the
San Jose improv this Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm gonna be [ __ ] spitting my
little San Jose
oh it's a great room yeah I'll be at the
San Jose Improv Thursday this Thursday
the
the 13th and the 14th you come on out
and see me you you [ __ ] go see him and
I'm in Colusa casino that is north towel
it's about an hour from Sacramento yeah
November 3rd and the November 30th I'm
in the Inland Empire Ontario improv that
takes longer to drive - it's right it's
out this gotta be the worst drive it's
tough man traffic one show only in both
cities t fat cake calm right now for
Brian and myself get them also Wednesday
5:00 p.m. Pacific only at T Frank a calm
we are releasing the chin dirties and
dick diver
it's take certified certified dick diver
both of our back get them now this is
the fine kid we're out